hello everybody it's Monday November
14th thank you everybody for being here
on this beautiful Mondays H3 podcast
back with another
action-packed week of shows
yes not with Elon Musk he uh apparently
apparently we don't have the funds to
get the real gilangma and although dude
fresh did get them uh Dude Perfect Dude
fret dude I'm so tired bruh dude fresh
oh my God
speaking of dude fresh this episode is
sponsored by honey we love them so much
thank you
um
we have so much fun things planned today
the main segment that we've got here for
you guys is the egg drop inspired by uh
our our friends of the show William
and um
you can see that yeah so we are gonna
compete we have five teams
of two
and we are gonna see who can Assemble
the most action-packed
drop proof egg sac
yes sir it's going to be exciting
me and Dan are going to win for sure I
already know exactly what I'm doing that
egg is not breaking
yeah it's gonna be fun
uh
oh I'm so tired you guys but anyway yeah
this the egg drop was inspired by uh
William Osmond from the show so it looks
fun and we're gonna do it God damn it
also Teddy fresh Black Friday sale
is still happening
that's right teddyfresh.com it'll I
think it's going through the end of
November
and uh there's still a bunch of good
[ __ ] up there although it's moving fast
so
get up there take a look steadyfresh.com
up to 70 off this Black Friday thank you
thank you
Wednesday Howie is coming turn people
Howie Mandel I'm nervous about it you're
nervous a little bit I'm excited I'm so
excited me and how are your dogs we're
like we're cool I feel like I was one of
those people I could say anything to
what we've been through you know I'm not
well I want to get canceled yeah we are
we're dogs I feel like you know whatever
you guys linked by the way is a dead
it doesn't work in the highway spot
wait was that the one he posted today
acknowledging the prolapse on Tick Tock
yeah yeah it's down oh no I just checked
it I got it backed up Howie yeah nice
try Howie it was such a funny Tick Tock
why is he got to be so embarrassed by
that nothing I felt like you just got to
be ready to talk on this prolapse by 48
hours from now because there's no way he
knows what he's getting yeah you know
that's good
that's going to be the whole episode
basically fine people
yeah so he posted a really funny Tick
Tock of
uh here actually we got it thank you
baby today we're going to talk about one
so wait how the [ __ ] do I is in Discord
how do I expand it uh here I'll play it
on I got it I got it I got it I got it I
think so yeah
a little tricky but
this is a tech episode we can figure
this out one of the most disturbing and
[ __ ] up videos to ever hit this app
yes I took it down okay okay
why didn't you rate tally stop
you're doing so good
[Applause]
yeah oh we're gonna have a lot of talk
about on uh on Wednesday so very excited
about that the number one podcast in the
world that's what I'm saying
actually a lot and a lot a hugely
eventful weekend uh my car was stolen
and destroyed
as well as my heart we'll talk about
that later but it's insane also Olivia
was attacked by a dog not kidding how
are you I'm okay I'm I'm on pain stuff
so it feels a little bit better but I
was indeed I was attacked by a pit bull
show me your uh um it's a gnarly it's
there's blood seeping through oh my god
dude yeah he he got me pretty bad did
you pull that up to the camera so they
can see the bandage are they allowed to
see blood it's just the bandage I don't
see you can see the blood seep through
the bandage just I don't just you know
from here can just cover the blood and
just so they can see the impact on me
what the heck yeah so so what happened I
was okay so I went to a party on
Saturday night my friend and I went back
to the house that she's dog sitting at
um she was told that the dog
um had previous trauma but the owners
didn't tell her that she couldn't let
the dog out to go to the bathroom if she
brought someone over and it had been a
few hours so it was time for the dog to
go to the bathroom and as soon as she
opened the door of the crate the dog
instead of going straight out to the
backyard took a detour and came straight
for me and I like knew what was
happening because I was being charged by
a pit bull so I was just like kind of
yelling and then it got a hold of my arm
and the only thing I could think of to
say was I just like told my friend to
let her know it was an emergency I just
screamed it's happening and then she
like grabbed the dog off of me and I ran
into the kitchen bleeding I don't know
why but the I don't know why but I'm
sorry to laugh at your trauma but you
screaming it's happening as your first
response to being attacked by a dog
because I was thinking in my head is
this gonna happen is this gonna happen
when the dog was coming to me
um but yeah then I went straight to the
ER and I was there
from like it was a long wait so I was
there from two to ten in the morning so
they make you guys wait in the lobby
with your arm all [ __ ] up
um well first they wrapped me and then
um I waited for like two hours and they
took me to the back to a bed and then I
waited and I got like IVs tetanus shots
all this stuff okay yeah Wow that's
scary and a pit bull I mean that's the
scariest dog yeah big one uh yes I
didn't realize however how serious
people are about the Pitbull smear
campaign I only wrote that a pit bull
was there and that was the dog that bit
me to let people know that it was big I
didn't want people to think that I was
like a [ __ ] and saying uh no Pitbull's
an important detail they're scary
they're scary yeah but no I I don't
think that it's because this dog was a
pit bull I think that the owners just
didn't instruct my friend properly for I
mean that's yeah I mean that is terrible
dogsmanship they were they were cool
with the the babysitter the dog was yeah
the babysitter they apparently she went
over and met him when the owners were
still there and she was totally fine
holy [ __ ] did she warn you that there
was a crazy dog in the house no I mean
like she she told me that she was dog
sitting and that's why she was doing oh
my God
and so the dog locked onto your arm bro
it hurt so bad like as soon as he
clamped because he tried to go from my
pocket and I had like my wallet or
something and so there are little holes
in the pants I was wearing there and so
he moved up then to my arm and as soon
as he latched on he just went like
harder and harder and it hurts so bad
were you thrashing around and the dog
was no no I think I was just like going
like this and it grabbed and then it
happened so fast like maybe three
seconds five seconds it was on me oh my
God yeah and then did you did you what'd
she do with the dog put it outside just
back in the crate back in the crate and
then did what did she call the owners
you called the police
my dad so I was freaking out bleeding
called my dad he came right to me and
then he took me to the ER so he was he
was a champ he stayed with me the whole
time too
[Applause]
um God that's terrifying that's so
[ __ ] scary dude thank you it's okay I
have a story now now I seem kind of
Brave as soon as it doesn't hurt anymore
she showed us like the wound and it's so
deep and you really are so brave Olivia
you dealt with that I can't even imagine
oh you [ __ ] my pants but people always
charging me
it's really deep you had to get stitches
it well they can't give stitches on high
risk injuries so like the high risk
injury dog bites because there's so much
bacteria on the dog so I'm still
bleeding like because it might yeah get
infected and then I need to treat it
yeah so apparently they only Stitch dog
bites when it's cosmetic or something
because it's gonna scar
so so they wow so you just have an open
[ __ ] wound
I'm just bleeding out over here but [ __ ]
so yeah what what kind of payments to
hook you up with Narco okay
nice so I'm feeling pretty good about it
nice nice dude that's crazy yeah
it's happening and what's with the dog
they're not gonna kill the dog
absolutely not okay no the people
haven't reached out to me yet dude
that's crazy I know the same [ __ ]
thing happened when I got attacked by
those two German Shepherds owner never
[ __ ] reached out to me and I spent
all night trying to rescue those [ __ ]
dogs man I don't want to sue I don't
want to do anything I would like an
apology though if I don't have it it
makes me bitter and it makes me laugh
just apologize man yeah
I think they're afraid of getting sued
so they're like better just not to say
anything but I don't know no if you say
sorry I won't
oh there it is you heard it here first
on camera otherwise
go straight to sell Goodman
or like you go cow style I just want to
make a quick note that uh Howie's Tick
Tock is still up I don't know why that
link wait was it so so wait send me the
link again okay
so lots of blood was it like gushing was
it bleeding it would look super deep do
you want to see if I can send you photos
yeah send me the photo I'll describe it
[ __ ]
that's scary
oh here it is yeah that was weird it
still says not it doesn't work for me
are you sure it's not cached or
something on yours uh no it look it just
says something went wrong now I'm just
on the tick tock app how he blocked you
it's working for me all right let me
just go to him if he blocked you because
you I'm not I don't think I'm even
logged in on this one okay
is it it's this one
yes it says never forget how I love the
comments oh he just knows that's young
gravy
at the top of the comments
it is oh [ __ ] young gravy my man did we
talk about it with young gravy I must
have I think so yeah I must have who
have you not talked about a single uh
the digital footprint has already been
spread everywhere it ain't going and we
ain't never forgetting Howie
yo
how's Neil doing
we will never forget no you're a legend
for that one it's amazing I love it
there's a whole culture it's a cult
around Howie's prolapse post
ah what a guy
great facial hair by the way on Howie ow
you send me the photo
yeah all right let me take a look I'm
trying to
save it in Discord maybe since my phone
is on Tick Tock yeah
what was the dog's name
Piper Oh I thought it'd be something
cute like tulip or something Donnie
Thomas name
dumbass man Piper
idiot dog oh yeah that's uh okay here's
the photo
oh [ __ ] yeah that's a dues
whoa I'm sending a few so you can see
the dimensions yes send me more
Scooby Dooby Doo the inappropriate
Scooby please
no yo Scooby-Doo be a lot different show
of Scooby had some balls [ __ ] people
up like this he's like yeah I mean he's
a Great Dane yeah that's a deep ass
there's like a bunch of deep ass tooth
gashes in your arms yeah you can see
where like his teeth tried to grab me
and then like
do you have a pet I wonder why he
thought he was so threatened by two dogs
and I was on my way to like sit down on
the floor to be less threatening too he
probably would have gone for your face
can you imagine he smelled your dogs
probably maybe yeah it's all Bowie's
fault [ __ ] but Chad's asking for you to
post it on Twitter I don't know if you
want to sure on our podcast yeah post it
to the Pod Twitter all right yeah you
got it love I don't think it's it's not
that um it's not as bad as a prolapse
anus no no definitely not as bad as that
yeah it is not as bad as that it's it's
not super gory but so you can tell it
looks like it's already been cleaned
right at this point yeah it had been
clean I think twice yeah
oh man
that's scary well I'm glad you're okay
thank you thank you
yeah on the uh on the weekend Olivia
just dropped in the chat guys I just got
a serious I think I just got seriously
attacked by a dog or something yeah we
were talking about God of War it's like
2 A.M
I'm like oh you're playing too she's
like no buy a pitbull
[ __ ]
you think pet do pitbulls get bad reps I
don't know they don't know didn't we
read a statistic that like a large
portion of all dog attacks are from
hippos
I'm not like kill pitbulls that's not my
thesis at all I'm just saying we did
have a discussion I don't remember what
the exact statistic was but we did have
a discussion about it
fact check that I remember it was some
like staggering percentage of dog
attacks
oh Mr Beast just passed uh PewDiePie
I was fast Jesus
that was fast as [ __ ] dude
111 million
tomorrow you said
PewDiePie has
oh yeah no he did he just passed him
love I prefer really not to yeah I said
uh that's not cool oh that's not cool
[ __ ] up yeah I knew that whole
subscribe to PewDiePie thing was a sham
and now look at him
he used us as Swedish people
did you post it on Twitter
uh yeah I just did yeah so you guys can
go check out the uh
the results here but man
Donnie
you'll have some cool scars
yeah I'll feel good about it yeah I
already feel good telling the story your
art you have good Mobility no permanent
damage it's just sore that's good
nice
all right well we're all glad you're
okay that was a very eventful uh scary
but good but glad you're okay but good
yeah not good and like not good but good
you know yeah yeah yeah dude I'm
freaking scared uh between 2005 and 2017
65 of total uh dog attacks were from
pitbulls that seems so insanely High I
almost don't believe it yeah I mean
there are some websites that are
discrediting that I know it's all over
the place because some people are but
that same website is saying because not
all these dogs should be identified as
pit bulls
but what website is that
uh the one that says it is 65 yeah uh
shoe house law
that's a law website yeah
does he specialize in dog attacks
I think so that's the one that I saw
Olivia we just found you some
representation oh my God
wait for me to reach out this is from a
statistica okay no it says the source is
dogsbyte.org
dogsbite.org hey what goes on on
dogsbite.orgy
uh dog bite victims is some serious dog
haters
it's about it's pretty much what you
don't dog bite victims what are you
trying to do what he wants to kill all
dogs that's all I'm saying
dogbite.org is a national dog bite
victim group dedicated to reducing
serious dog text we conduct research on
the growing but under reported public
safety issue of severe fatal dog attacks
inflicted by dangerous dog breeds we
Champion the rights of victims through
our research education advocacy okay
seems legit
so here this is interesting Pitbull's
number one by far now is that the result
of a pit bull being an aggressive dog or
like psychotic people that like
aggressive dogs tend to
get pit bull
I've always I think it's probably a
combination of the two it the the those
two things that you just named play off
each other in such a way yeah a lot of
rescued pit bulls were fighting dogs so
like
they're literally trained to kill
yeah I mean Shredder bites people every
day and so I don't see him on this I
don't see Yorkies on the list well I
think that's part of it too is you know
the
the pitbull's uh bite is so powerful
that when it does attack it is much more
likely for it to be severe and somebody
end up hospitalized so it probably is
significantly unreported for small dogs
because yeah small dogs
if Shredder had a stronger job we'd have
been sued into Oblivion by now let me
tell you straight up that's a menace
yeah uh uh Wallace
we gotta walk now Wallace is so funny
bad dog
Rottweilers German Shepherds the two
dogs almost killed me
and Shredder I have a German shepherd
mixed breed how they just gonna [ __ ] on
mixed breed isn't that like a I guess
that's like all other dogs
your mom just messaged me did she
already hear me say that about Wallace
she's coming to her defense oh no it's
unrelated
she said I read 25 were pit bulls with
Labrador uh Labradors second in bites no
Labradors are not the aggressive
didn't where'd she get her stats not
dogsbytes.org
I'm not sure she just sent me that
message I'll probably get another one
about Wallace in a second though since I
mentioned that so anyway okay well there
you go we got to the bottom of it uh for
more info go to dogsbyte.org
uh we're changing the world for the
better over there
moving on
excuse me goddamn
I haven't been smoking or anything but
I think it's the weather change I've had
the heater on my house and my nose I'm
just bleeding from my nose all the time
I got bloody bugs some coughing
you're just you're just randomly getting
nosebleeds from it's from the furnace
sure yeah because it gets all dry yes I
can't think of the last time that that
happened to me when I was a kid I used
to get nose you know most kids do I used
to get nosebleeds all the time yeah I
genuinely can't remember the last time
that's happened because you know it's
just randomly it's like oh I'm bleeding
now it's not like when I was a kid where
it would just be like waterfall of blood
sure yeah it's pretty it you know huh
there's lots of blood in my nose all the
time
yo I saw I got an email from Jimmy Lee
today
what day do you not
well that's kind of what I was wondering
he sent me an email about something like
that he was going to be in LA and that
uh he's my best friend and uh let's do
something exciting together
and I decided to search his email
and lo and behold since I've known Jimmy
he's he's emailed me 374 times as Jimmy
Lee
and that seems low really I don't know I
had pages and pages and Pages bro that's
50 emails per page I had to click a lot
of times to get to the best sure but I
mean that you've known him for what five
six years now something like that I
guess maybe even longer Steve Rossi has
emailed me 44 times oh of course of
course his uh elusive publicist for a
total of like what is that for 30 or
something okay yeah we're getting that's
a lot of [ __ ] emails dude he must
have called me uh 20 times over the
weekend see this is why I'm saying it
seems low it's based off the volume of
uh calls really cool I'll do that many
times open your missed calls do you
answer them or do you [ __ ] no
he he was he was in town
um you know I'll text him I'll keep tabs
on him but you'll never be able to get
off so how many missed calls you get
from him go let's get the exact number
okay let's see
two three four
five I was exaggerating but five five is
still alive
um
like just kept texting me pictures memes
that he posts so he'll like send it to
me after he posts it yeah he he emails
me the memes a lot yeah Zach you you
actually respond to him but I don't and
he still sends me on the mailing list
there so like I get everything he posts
on his Instagram he's so fantastic how
can you dislike Jimmy Lee the man is
like he's a force of nature there's
nobody like him in the whole planet so
this band is emailing me like 430 times
bro so he messaged me Saturday was are
you going out tonight with gang I said
are you in La he's all come today need
fomo with you
come out come with us tonight Big Daddy
need the zacker then he sent me a
picture
I said who's going he said I got Paulie
and Pat my buddies it's bullying fast
hey hey meet me at this oh I remember
the email he sent me
he said bring the cameras let's go to a
restaurant I'm gonna tear that place up
I'm gonna go in the kitchen and make a
crazy fomo for you guys then he said
bring one of your buddies probably
shoshone's which is the restaurant he
was going to do need Zach on team kid
get a B we're going to Shoney's get the
team together
we're gonna create some fomo did he
refer did I understand that he referred
to himself as big big daddy in one of
those uh come out with us tonight Big
Daddy I think he called that referring
to me as Big Daddy yeah okay
um and then
I said I'll let you know I'll keep you
posted he said dope it is dope on a rope
with some soap
he's always on even in text and then the
last text was fomo Hotel made that
Craig's tonight major football
no Zach you're missing out on our group
chat one time oh [ __ ] there's another
chat too he says Zach we're insulting
all the customers and they're dying
laughing where are you
this is major fomo major all caps major
what what is this why is it saying more
posts from Jimmy Lee I just want Jimmy
Lee hold it I click in this link you
send hibby
and it did he rate okay here God damn
why does it do that you see that yeah so
you guys saw that I'm not crazy I'm not
crazy I saw it getting fomo over here
yeah say it what the [ __ ] what kind of
fomo is this go to his profile yeah yeah
I just think he's profiling yeah Jimmy's
been [ __ ]
he hasn't missed a day on the memes man
although Jimmy if I'm be honest dude and
I know you're probably watching this
listen you on Horseback ushering Native
Americans on the Trail of Tears it's not
funny the Wounded Knee is not something
that you like you have to know that
the Native Americans is the probably the
single biggest genocide in American
history so let's not laugh about the
Trail of Tears okay it's just not cool
listen Jimmy you handing a blanket with
smallpox
is really not a good vibe bro
he has a new Breaking Bad post with
Walter Jr now becoming Heisenberg
the other thing I post so much like what
the [ __ ] where's the one
you gotta keep going look at this [ __ ]
the Jake Paul Andrew Tate Meetup
what the [ __ ] man how are you so active
on here he's got a team of like 20
people he does he's like insane but
these people he's hired are actually
like really internet Savvy that's the
weird part
I know they're Phantom I think it's just
fans I think it's just fun sending it in
it's definitely fans but the they're
really deep fried high level memes you
handled the chip Dan have you tried
these
[Laughter]
[Music]
get in loser we're making fomo
so there was another text he sent me
that I'd like to read I said I after
like I'll keep you posted he said come
on pal how many times can you say you
hang out with a real celebrity
referring to him referring to him
he's kidding he's gotta be I don't know
anymore dude it's all right this is hard
to tell Rory Hicks thank you man what's
this about the stolen car let me know if
you want the mole peeps to build you an
underground drilling something yeah
that's where we are residents I'll get
to the uh thank you for the Dono I'll
get to the um
this stolen car here in a minute yeah it
[ __ ] sucks
I forgive you for all the things you
never apologize for uh Dan He forgives
you for saying you don't like him maybe
which one are you looking at right here
he says I forgive you
for all the things you never apologize
for
sorry
these are all okay oh I actually I I
actually really like the uh no the God
of War one that he posted my story it
will not let me open this image
this is the one that bugged out cursed
okay next to it look I'll just zoom in
there it is
bro we can't play it it's cursed
it's too much you know what would be
epic if Jimmy paid to promote this oh
yeah oh that'd be a high level play now
he's gonna do that
do it man
where's the God of War One let's look at
one more here uh keep going keep going
there in the middle got a phone
cease these old-timey jokes boy
father when can I go out on my own I've
Got the Whole World the Pinocchio it's
the father father
did
these meme makers are wildly [ __ ] you
know what to say about it but okay there
it is so shout out Jimmy
is he still in La uh Zach I believe so
yeah I can feel his presence
[Music]
I mean he knows where we were is he
gonna show up and just shout our names
now he's going to
I mean that oh what a man if he does
that
oh you're not invited but if you can
post up outside and get our attention
you can come in
you know
there it is
wait a minute
story looks like he's posing up with the
Sun
he's sorry can I look at yours on on
yeah I think so yeah it's like a sack
look like
yeah
it's like a sack
he gets he gets recognized a lot now in
public because uh
his time on the show and he just yeah he
likes to hit the bus
um oh this this um
floated to the top of our
subreddit and I've totally [ __ ]
forgot about this holy [ __ ] yeah the
first comment is how do people find this
and that's the truth of it
Ethan Klein School picture showing he
was in Jesus Christ commitment Club
dude I forgot about this [ __ ] this is
crazy blast from the past
totally committed is a club for those
who are ready to display their relation
to Jesus Christ to make a commitment to
serve him completely this club
organization uh commemoration Christmas
Child I I it's cut off Jesus members can
also be seen spreading
candy canes at Christmas time and
treating treats for teachers during
teacher appreciation I don't know
whatever week oh Jesus yes so
I don't know why it looks so small
yeah so I think what happened was
I heard that it was during yearbook um
day at school and all the groups and
clubs
and I heard that Jesus appreciation Club
was getting together for the yearbook
and the gymnasium and I just decided to
show up for the lulls just for the photo
then none of them knew me I'd never been
there and they all let me sit it was a
really small club that let me sit in how
did they let you bro they let me sit in
they didn't say [ __ ] that's so weird and
the thing I guess everybody knew I was
Jewish I had like I was kind of like
my whole routine back then was just like
oh I'm Jewish so everybody knew I was
Jewish gotcha and I boy they were afraid
of being like they were like is this
offensive is this anti-semitic if we
kick him out I guess just let him take
my photo people didn't even think about
whatever if anti-Semitism was a thing
yeah I know that's true I think they
were just I don't know I didn't think
about it I just thought it'd be fun I
was crazy bro Back Then I Had No
Boundaries now what compared yeah as
opposed to now yeah it really rained it
in and yeah sat in on a photo and
smiling I don't know it's pretty CR but
[ __ ] I don't know there's a teacher here
A bunch of kids I never [ __ ] met
and I went by myself just cruised in sat
down
to like sit in the middle kind of dude
that takes ball and the front right next
to the teacher that takes balls or maybe
do it with enough confidence you know
sometimes people
are like that's great no wonder you can
nail the preacher voice so well you
studied it I was gonna say I wonder if
I've seen you do your preacher voice now
and recognize you well I hope not
so your name is not it's not on there
anywhere so someone finding this is
pretty impressive huh I think I'm
assuming that here let me go to the next
page what is this oh yeah just zoom in
of me
on a psycho
that's so funny it was funny though I
totally forgot about this
uh I'm assuming they have copies of all
the years book years and someone was
just flipping through my grad year
which was like two thousand right
four
no
three right from high school I was at
five and I believe you're two years
older than me so
or wait aren't you like six years seven
years older than me 42 no minus 35 no
that's seven thirty seven forty two
today
42 today it's not my birthday's in June
[Applause]
all right that's enough
exactly it's just you know what I mean
I'm sensitive and you guys you know it
just throws me off it's just I'm 37 so
so yeah you must have been 03. I don't
think I graduated in O3 I think it was
o4
okay if your birthday is late in the
year sometimes yeah maybe you're only
one grade ahead of me yeah it was in
June this year also my mom held me back
between kindergarten I tell that story
my mom literally said you fail
kindergarten my teacher failed me in
kindergarten right that you're too
[ __ ] to [ __ ] have fun
that explains it then yeah yeah 2004. so
there was and my maturity really shows
doesn't it folks
that's crazy
there it is that explains the G the
comments were pretty funny though
someone's like he was definitely there
for a girl which is funny because I was
in another club for a girl I didn't give
a [ __ ] what club but it wasn't like
religious [ __ ] it was like uh
what the [ __ ] was it still curious what
you got roped into for a girl
I almost got roped into uh Academic
Decathlon for a girl once
academic decaf that's like the the like
academic like competition where uh
like schools around the country compete
in like
you know trivia essentially oh okay not
just trivia but you know uh and
yeah I was seeing a girl that was in
there and she tried really hard to get
me to join but
nope nope I think it was like nerd [ __ ]
I think it was like the lamest [ __ ] like
the Rotary Club the Rotary Club yeah um
I didn't know why any of these people
were wasting their [ __ ] time there
it's like the dumbest [ __ ] dude the
rotary we had to uh start a club in high
school like that was like at our senior
year we had to start a club
it's cool if it's your own club like
what club did you make the rock and roll
appreciation Club there you go see
that's vibes
you know
so yes I'm committed to Jesus Christ as
everybody well knows
actually
I want to point out before we get too
deep in it last year we um
we
put out sets of trading cards that did
extremely well it was a super mega hit
this year the trading cards are back and
better than ever
just like last year let's go 100 of the
profits is going to the crew yeah boy
and uh the cards are so beautiful
let me open them up do I have an
overhead cam yeah let me let me show you
guys this is available
at um we'll spam the link and it's also
in the description
it's uh T trading dot shop trdng.shop
now
I don't wanna there's a prolapse one in
here I don't want to show even the
Blurred ones so I need to be careful
about
where that one's located okay I think
it's the very last one yeah I see
yes so um oh we're also selling the
first pack interesting
so what's cool about this one too here
I'll do open this like a Pokemon thing
is that there's rare cards that aren't
in every pack the Bolden prolapse we
have here I'm not going to show you
because it's still graphic but here you
have my friend Neil
and then we have the uncensored gold one
and it's in a protected 18 plus case
it's gorgeous the Creator by the way Max
is with us
hey everybody
it's me I made a the god of trading
yeah so let's take a look here at the at
this year's pack 100 goes to the crew
guys
Ethan apology Podium and they're all how
do you call this hologram holographic
yeah holographic
and those are premium right of course
yeah bring the best for you thanks bro
here's Ila The X Factor reel it in
holographic baby
Dan oh this one's sick scorpion chair
that looks like a real magic card yeah I
did and shout out to cam he did most of
the art on the squares oh he came out
great damn you did great yo Jilly's awk
this looks like a rare hey dude
that's powerful man
[Music]
180 HP
oh
a b
ongo boxer oh that's quite nice I like
the the marrying of the Two Worlds
Olivia
delete it bald
Olivia exposes your opponent's hairline
lowering their morale and causing them
to have
on the rest of the weekend
Ian The Thinker whoa
Cameron Bunny Hop AKA like Snow White
vibes
she's the Critter princess right yeah
yes you feel like Snow White I never can
I wish no a little bit when I feed
squirrels I do there you go
love oh yeah dude this is everything
hell yeah baby dog my [ __ ]
[Music]
Sam anyone here from Arizona oh this is
a um fortnite reference and also but you
also do build here on the show
that's a nice one there Sam Lena the
spice Queen
true although she was dethroned by Dan
but we don't need to talk about that
right Lena to be determined yeah
she that's true
this is so beautiful oh my God
puppies I'll Shredder and Alfredo dog
responsible for most dog attacks in
America right here Shredder
families
that's so nice
Boomer bash leftovers
that would be Hassan uh penetrating me
from behind
I'm very proud of that shot Pride minute
I love this
60-second celebration guys celebrate
Pride minute with us here at the HP
podcast
ab's burrito oh yeah that's a special
that's a highly coveted card and
technical difficulties uh and of course
the prolapse here these all all the
profits guys 100 of our cut goes to the
crew very exciting and so there's
there's a censored prolapse card in
every pack every pack has the same 18
cards and then we have a thousand gold
uncensored prolapse cards that we're
just gonna put in the bubble mailers the
golden ticket and then we have one
golden ticket that we're inserting in
one of the packs
and we gonna give a massive grand prize
to someone I'm not sure
yet
I think it depends where you look like
if you're in America we're thinking oh
we'll fly out to the show put you up and
you can be
for the show if you want
you know
uh so or but if you're like if you're in
like Serbia or some [ __ ] like
just just feel like it gets a little
complicated at that point we love our
Serbian fans we do but maybe I'll do
something else for you I don't know what
try to make it work if you're in Serbia
but I'm not I don't make a promise to
the serbians
uh the the uh golden prolapse comes in
this
so and care and consideration
that nobody has their if only Howie
opened his Tick Tock with this am I
right
congrats inside of this protective
protector lies the Elusive and rare
golden prolapse card this really is an
uncensored prolapse anus inside of this
protector seriously there's an 18 plus
card you have been worn please do not
open this unless you want to see a
uncensored prolapsed anus please don't
love peace and love you can you can
probably pull out just the name like
just let's see half an inch of it
that's the best part is you can really
uh okay so I can do like yeah like this
yeah but it's golden
my friend Neil
you can see a little bit of the staining
you all know what comes next the gold
really brings out the uh crevices I feel
yeah it's actually quite nice the way
you guys framed it where the prolapse is
over the frame beautiful really classic
we went through eight or nine different
design drafts over the last couple of
months for just the gold prolapse cards
it's gorgeous it's really you guys
talked uh really top to yourselves this
year so
head on over to uh uh trading spelled
trdng.shop links in the description and
we have
um we just had a couple left over of the
um the first pack the oh okay so so
there's like 400 left those are gonna go
really quickly they were just some
extras we have 2500 in stock and those
are going to go out for Christmas and
then we're gonna open a pre-order until
December 3rd at 11 59 Eastern Standard
Time and then after that you will not be
able to get these anymore
so yeah just to reiterate if you order
within the first 2500 packs you will get
it before Christmas yes those are made
ready to go that is the goal with
international shipping obviously some
domestic yeah that's a good point if
you're if you again live in Serbia let's
temper our expectations okay you live in
Serbia for Christ's sake
but to everyone who lives domestically
you're going to get those uh and before
Christmas now you can buy if you're past
2500 you can buy it's going to remain
open for pre-sales and there's going to
be a lot so feel free to pre-sale and
then we're going to close it the
pre-sale December 3rd at 11 59 Eastern
Standard Time yeah and then those will
all ship out to you guys
um q1 so like January February there it
is there it is thank you thank you so
this is exciting once again all the
profits that we get are going straight
to the cruise so that is a beautiful
thing so we love them in the last seven
days Ethan yeah we have had uh
six thousand one hundred and thirty six
views from Serbia just so you know uh
that's why I'm calling them out I'm
saying hey if you get that golden ticket
in Serbia we'll talk
but I think I'm comfortable saying if
you're domestic we'll bring you out to
the show we'll put you up
and um
we'll have Jimmy Lee roast you or
something I don't know also I wanted to
shout out one more thing at the live
show we have these brand new cars
these are exclusive for the live show
the Arts done by day off limited on
Instagram they've worked with some of my
favorite creators before like are we
selling this at the library
here
I'm putting it
yeah I just showed up to the camera the
design is so dope they killed it they
were the best please follow them
so this was a bad choice too but you get
the idea it's the same as the poster
that we realized
so yeah we're um let's post it we'll
post the image online so people can see
it but
um people are Wonder saying how do they
how do we put in the golden ticket is
that gonna be in the first 2500 or how
how are we gonna decide on the golden
ticket it'll probably be in the first
2500 if it's for the live show
um right so people get it in time okay
yeah again that makes sense first 2500
are gonna sell out quickly and then the
shop will update and it'll say pre-order
so you'll know exactly what you're going
to be in so if you really want something
for Christmas
um they're they're almost we're almost
out of the 2500 so wow really yeah crazy
wait how much how much is a pack 25 25
bucks and you get all 18 cards in every
single pack so there's they're not
random the only thing that's random is
these the golden prolapse so yeah the
lucky thousand will get two prolapses
one regular and a golden chair Christmas
is one day
Christmas is one day yet the pro the
gays got a whole month
the lucky prolapse they will that will
be spread out in both drops right yeah
yeah and yeah we're um we're over
halfway sold out on the year okay I
didn't stop once Okay cool so you want
to order so once again if you want the
chance to win the golden ticket it's
going to be in the first 2500 just
because
we wanted it to be for the live show so
there you have it
um and thank you thank you rap trading
or sorry you're trading now the rap got
dropped why'd you drop the rap I started
off working in music working with
musicians and then I worked oh that's
what yeah yeah and then I uh ended up
working with this little podcast with
all these fun guys on it and um I've
just been working with creators a lot
recently are you talking about us yeah
yeah I was like one of them being a
little cheeky being a little cheeky yeah
but um but yeah since you guys have
worked with really awesome creators like
Nick is not green and Gabby Bell and
um just a bunch of people if you are a
Creator and you want to work with me
reach out to me on my website
um but yeah I I'm super super proud of
these uh Sam thank you so much for being
so amazing and helping me with this
project and it's just a uh it's a dream
come true I've been watching you guys
for forever so thanks bro yeah you make
a great product man I'm stoked on it
it's like so beautiful it really is high
level stuff thank you and also if if you
email me or reach out to me or whatever
um it's just me I'm I'm the whole
company so um so yeah just uh appreciate
the patience with everything and uh yeah
your customer support I'm everything bro
you got to get customer support you're
just you sold 2500 packs yeah you got to
hire someone to answer your emails I
mean you know that's that's the goal
that's the goal right you know I really
want to build that's the game
but um yeah thanks for the support guys
I'm really happy everybody loves them
yeah I love it yeah by the way love
you're saying that on the first drop is
on eBay for 200 bucks no did someone buy
it but it's been posted uh for 200 to
300 wow
there's a resale Market apparently very
big yeah so um anyway are those PSA
rated oh of course of course didn't we
try can we send the prolabs to get PCA
created you know they rate that the the
Pokemon craze has uh seemingly died down
so they probably have um because the
only reason we didn't remember we were
going to get those um
Gulf War cards rated yes but then PSA
the company that does that literally
closed submissions because it was
becoming almost they were completely
overwhelming yeah bro I wanted my George
Bush card braided bro yeah but uh that
was uh over a year ago now so they're
they're probably no problem
I mean is that [ __ ] up or can we send
the prolapse in together uh I mean it's
a service without any like it's a
warning although Howie showed it to all
of us without any warnings love says
it's okay what do you what do you think
just like oh there's some asthma what do
you think Max whatever yeah I mean I I
don't know I my I was surprised that my
manufacturer uh was cool making a
thousand gold did they say anything no
they didn't say [ __ ] no it actually took
a second I had to like reprint them and
I really thought they were just gonna
say no and then we just weren't gonna
have them but I wonder how many people
had to handle and look at those I think
a lot with no explanation yeah well you
know like Dan said you know everybody
had to see those it's a Job saying they
only rate certain cards you can't just
send any card yeah you need a petition
going yeah let's go let's get them
officially unfortunately so wait do they
uh do we know if they rate the Gulf War
okay well those were like official tops
cards so it I mean as funny as it is
maybe
man the barricades all right thank you
to uh thank you to Max we'll I'll keep
promoting it through uh the end of
December but yeah it goes all to the
crew guys this is very cool very fun
and uh we love to support the crew here
uh
uh don't if we do we love it we love it
we will we be without our beautiful crew
ladies and gentlemen I'll be paying them
in fupa coin by the way the exchange
rate has gotten very bad on that so bear
with me oh no this is Cameron meanwhile
Cameron be like
H3 trading back uh
uh
money
money
by the way the uh a lot of people in the
chat were trying to give you an out that
you misspoke and you meant Siberia not
Serbia when you were uh wait a Serbia
not a country no it is so what so you
did mean Serbia what's wrong with Serbia
there's nothing wrong it's very far away
it's just in Europe yeah okay I mean
what the [ __ ] I'm just saying yeah it
could be Serbia it could be [ __ ]
turkey it could be Egypt could be
Germany I don't know it's just it could
be complicated if you live in Europe you
can get to travel to the Kazakhstan
Siberia okay [ __ ]
all right we are we are uh over for
doing our ad uh so we should do that uh
we have one ad let me thank them honey
and then we'll get back and talk about
my car that was stolen
oh I really don't it's so [ __ ] up I
just got that car
dude
all right
let's stop so I'll just think honey then
we'll come back and get into it
thank you so much to honey we love honey
you'd have to be insane to be browsing
without honey
literally nuts
today's episode is sponsored by Honey
the easy way to save When shopping on
your iPhone or computer
I save me and Ila save like on a daily
basis
um
the codes work so widely on the internet
that you're gonna be getting those every
day in my experience
um
and thanks to 100 for coupon codes the
thing of the past honey is the free
shopping tool that scours the internet
for promo codes and applies the best one
it finds your cart imagine you're
shopping at one of your favorite sites
and when you click check out the honey
button appears and all you have to do is
Click apply coupon wait a few seconds as
honey searches for coupons you can find
for that site and if honey finds a
working coupon you will watch the price
drop magically
furniture
food computer parts like
clothing the the savings are insane and
you just go to check out
my favorite is I'm just shopping like
normal and then all of a sudden when
you're getting ready to check out and
pay full price Honey's like uh
is there someone you forgot to ask like
the consent meme
and it's like I agree on this price they
agree with on this price honey is there
someone you forgot to ask yes
honey just hit you with that ten dollar
off coupon that five dollar off coupon
that you know in this case twenty dollar
off coupon
and it's basically free money I mean it
really is so easy to use it drops down
you click it it automatically applies it
it's boom bomb bang Bob's your uncle you
don't even have to think about it thank
you Crowder uh you can save even more
when you ask Connie to keep track of
price drops on your holiday shopping
list
if the price drops on anything on your
list you'll instantly get an alert to
let you know that's cool you know you
know how often Amazon messes with its
prices it's insane like if you track the
price of certain items on Amazon it's
going up and down all the time huge
swings so that's actually really useful
there if you don't already have honey
you could be straight up missing out and
by getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting this show thank you
I use honey I love honey
and
um so get
PayPal honey get PayPal honey for free
what does that mean
we'll just get PayPal honey mean
you see that
get PayPal honey for free at
joinhoney.com h3tv
what is PayPal hunting do you see that
I I don't I don't know do you see what
I'm talking about though I see it yep
okay that's joinhoney.com
slash H3 uh yeah please support our
sponsor honey is a great one and we love
him very much so thank you guys thank
you thank you to honey we love you
can you ask what's PayPal honey that was
like I just
I'm sure they're gonna let us know now I
gotta know what that is
I didn't do anything wrong I just don't
know what the [ __ ] that is
do you see it
I love honey
okay let's talk about
um
let's talk about this [ __ ]
[Music]
um
actually there's a Daniel texted me he
was watching live oh honey dang it right
PayPal honey oh that's they changed
their name okay so that makes sense
because they were calling out honey the
whole time and then they drop a PayPal
honey at the end
honey has joined the PayPal family
PayPal honey interesting
that's interesting
all right thank you Daniel
I have handlers they watch the show live
to make sure yep there's a team they go
They're gonna eat is doing the arteries
okay they get the whole team watching
actually before I talk about my car
being stolen
there's actually just a couple more
things we want to hit on
Nick Cannon we keep talking about how
he's repopulating the Earth
but
the crazy thing is the names of his kids
um
his name the names of these kids is
pretty wild
it's like he ran out of ideas
when you have that many kids where's the
list of names guys can you just paste it
in there for me and I I don't see any
names here they're the Bold on top of
each one beautiful day
or if you just want the subreddit meme
it's right here here is
Monroe and Moroccan Scott
we'll pull this one up
yeah this is better
so here is the name of
Nick Cannon's children
and I get it when you having like what
is this nine well he's got more than
that this is old he's got like 14 now
doesn't he
uh he has 12 12. yeah uh not all of them
are born yet though oh I see I see okay
there's three cooking right now Monroe
cannon that's normal that's nice age 11
Moroccan Scott Cannon
fine moroccan's a little bit unusual but
it's not that it's fine now this gets a
little off the rails golden sagin
[Music]
golden sagin cannon that's a lot that's
like a tongue twister yo I got that
golden sagin
what is sagging is that something I
don't know what that is it's probably
Sargon golden Sagan
stack on these nuts
is that what you're saying yes let's
[ __ ] go right now dude sorry [ __ ]
go right now
so [ __ ] hyped right now this one's
Vibe powerful Queen Cannon
that's when you're like totally out of
ideas that's my finisher move um and my
Mecca anime
powerful Queen
Cannon when your name is a daily
affirmation
I'm powerful Queen good morning my queen
so wait what do we call her is it just
power powerful Queen what do we call her
PQ pqc
I think he got a taste for a little bit
of the wild side because the next baby's
name is Rise Messiah Cannon
in order rise Messiah
that's that's wild I don't even know
what the [ __ ] bro
rise Messiah clearly the mothers have no
uh participation in these naming
because these are these are way too I
think in my opinion
there's a theme here and he's the theme
ain't no way these different women are
coming up with these crazy ass names
that's true rise Messiah
uh the next one zillion hair zillionaire
she could be she'd be inherent in no
zillions if you keep having the kids at
this rate
[Music]
three million dollars a year in child
support
[Music]
even Elon Musk can support these many
kids
Zion
mix lydian
with a scale
mixolydian oh it's a musical skill yeah
Zion mixolydian which makes sense for
the second one the one below it
beautiful Zeppelin Cannon there we go
there I love how he's just throwing in
adjectives into the name now nice nice
Zeppelin sweet uh cool Zeppelin
funny Zeppelin
let's see here Zen Cannon okay Vibes no
middle name
baby Cannon yeah you can name your child
baby that's horrible you literally just
forgot he's at this point you forgot
he's just like uh baby I don't know [ __ ]
yeah it's like when you name your dog
dog it's like baby
yeah that baby's not born yet that's
just baby candy oh thanks let's just
forget about it then
but why is here it says I mean baby's
more believable than half of these wait
but look the way it's formatted it's
because it's magic
[Music]
legendary love
that's pretty cool that's a cool name
pretty cool it's pretty cool
and then finally
um Onyx Ice Cole Cannon
Onyx they got four games this
[ __ ] just randomly picked words
out of the dictionary
just a random word generation come on
dude
powerful Queen Cannon is sending me
because it sounds like the name a unit
of soldiers will call their Cannon
during World War One or something
powerful Queen
yeah I just went to that website cam
randomwordgenerator.com let's see yeah
let's get uh two random words Canon
Arena hair Cannon
Vibes Union release Cannon love it
dialogue survey Cannon and do it
huge reporter Canada
that's right
horoscope chin Canon okay I love that
I love that piece display Cannon
preparation if that's almost like
preparation X here adjectives are no
just all I guess you know just all and
then first letter last letter should be
man what the [ __ ]
let's do it
medicine body
that's a good one for you Nick medicine
body Cannon
I like that
Andy Equinox
but if I save okay base fill
chart slippery no definition no
definition Canon negotiation for us well
that one's the beta of the bunch humor
no split Cannon
people saying
remedy remedy okay this one's
interesting this one actually he might
use remedy homosexual Canon like you
gotta fix the gay he's a religious guy
so who's gay
mean radical Canon
salad bulletin Cannon I'd feel that
solid bulletin all right so there you go
uh Nick and the next kids just use that
and uh it'll save you some time yep
there it is
net Cannon
he's repopulating the world
the Lord knows we need it oh and then
there's one more actually there's two
more things and they're both really good
she gives me happy we talked about it so
I get emotional I talk about the next
thing but David dobrik commissioned
yo is this [ __ ] out of pocket
David dobrik commissioned an artist to
make an eye that's all gouged out and
crazy
and he says it's modeled after my actual
eyeball
it's just a little bit out of pocket bro
he's [ __ ] He's stunting on Jeff with
this you've di'd two people and now
you're adorning your house with eyes you
gotta [ __ ] sick I feel like the image
of an eye should be at least a little
triggering at this point right but it
remind you of the guilt
or or or or the pleasure right like a
serial killer has uh you know trinkets
[Music]
dude this is blood slides he has an eye
sculpture for every eye he takes
this is crazy why the eye bro
is it intentional do you think is he
trying to send a message how could it
not well this artist how good it
specializes in in eye art like that's
what she does sure so if he was getting
something from her it was gonna be an
eye right yeah but just don't get
something from her right exactly that's
what I'm saying it like has to be okay
did he not he wanted an eye I know he's
like pissed maybe he's like looking for
an eye and he didn't get it from Jeff so
he's like trying to find it somewhere
else he's a bloodborne boss
oh uh Inari says hi Ethan I want to say
thank you for being US Open about your
Tourette's mental health I'm 21.
and have been diagnosed with Tourette's
ASD on what's ASD
ADHD and PTSD if it was autism spectrum
disorder man you got the whole [ __ ]
Full House yeah you got all your You
Gotta [ __ ] you know you gotta doubt
everything God's like I'll just [ __ ]
just give them everything
give them the works yeah man
is I don't know if that's a male or
woman's name but yeah dude you
you got it you got it
that's crazy you got you know what's
weird like the red syndrome usually goes
hand to hand with all the kind of other
[ __ ] up [ __ ] like ADHD
and stuff but
um
thank you you're gonna be great just get
oh I did get a text from Jeff oh Jeff
wants to call him yes oh he hasn't seen
it he said what eye statue holy [ __ ] you
got to be kidding me yeah I'm down the
calling okay okay this is great how does
he call in Dan uh here I'll send him a
zoom link or I'll send it to you and
then you send it to him yeah I'm sending
sending it in our main chat right now
that's awesome that we broke the story
okay hold on Jeff's gonna call in this
is great
it's great okay Ethan subreddit comment
says David collects the eyes of his
friends to form one giant eye like Ethan
collects the hairlines of all his
enemies
okay this is awesome thank you Jeff he's
my bestie by the way
right yeah I've heard really clearly
Yeah in our you you'll be good man I'm
glad you're getting help though that's
really important because I had you know
my anxiety disorder which I think is
related to Tourette's in some way and
ADHD
once you tie it all together and start
treating that everything makes it starts
to make a lot more sense
apparently Inari uh uh is a word in is a
name in Japanese a proper noun in
Japanese but also in Finnish of all
things so it's probably more likely
Finnish than Japanese but we love that
for you all right so let me know if
if a full Jeffy boy gets back to you so
excited to talk to Jeff
uh so you sent it to him yeah all right
I am keeping an eye on the zoom to see
if he joins yes yes
yeah I was um I was talking to Jeff and
he told me that he used to do a show
with Jonah you know Jonah he's part of
the Vlog Squad and everything Jeff or
David actually almost killed him too
when that motorcycle stunt
but Jeff said that David's telling
everybody to not he's demanding that
people don't associate with Jeff because
he's toxic and [ __ ] so Jonah literally
stopped working
with Jeff because of David Jeff's toxic
yeah okay yeah Jeff's talks it
okay the dude whose face got slammed
into an excavator by David okay
yeah those people are still riding with
David it's crazy
a vlog Squad gotta know that this is a
little [ __ ] crazy
whoa
they take it they take it as a warning
it is this is a straight up warning
don't forget what I did to the last guy
who crossed me
anybody uh go to the pizza place oh yeah
it's like still lined up around the
block really insane oh wow
okay God [ __ ] damn it
this man's still selling pies and he's
got an eye in his house and y'all still
buying pizza for me
they had
listen Jeff
you dare to
talk to me
you want to sue me for it slamming your
face into an excavator
here's a picture of your other eye
it looks good in my office
be a shame if something happened to your
other eye
you can't see
be happy for the one eye you've got you
understand me
I'll send the pie compliments of dobrik
papa doe brick
I'll send you a fisheye pie jump
destroying the lobby yes
[Music]
that's the magic of life do you know
what I'm saying you can't do this
pre-recorded true well yeah I mean live
um just not as fun is that
all right uh I just hit accept
we are waiting uh Jeff wittick friend of
the show
to discuss the eye
okay drum roll this video just waiting
on him to connect to audio
David that's interesting hey I hear him
hey friend of the show Jeff whittak is
here yes how are you
good good this is
just hell he's my sound bite guy hey
Kyle nice to see you again
thanks
shout out again
love you too Kyle did that mean a lot to
you Kyle
yeah yeah it did yeah I see that he's
Zack's a big deal in the industry
it is
it really is you know it used to be a
real discipline back here in the radio
day but it's a forgotten art it's a lost
art and Zach is um
what would you say you're you're
re-lighting the flame uh is that right
I'm I'm trying my best to do that yeah
yeah but I appreciate the compliment
guys thank you very much
you're crushing it over there a big fan
of the show we are over here at Jeff FM
yeah Jeff F uh Jeff FM so uh Jeff FM
that's funny to say Jeff FM
you hadn't see the um the eyeball I was
you hadn't seen that until I sent it to
you
I mean Ethan for me to live a healthy
life I can't watch what this [ __ ]
psychopath does all day long but thank
you for sending it to me and me on a
tear all day oh because now my blood is
boiling so then I'm just messing up
I don't get too emotional about it
but what are your thoughts what do you
want me to say no I'm curious I guess
what I'm curious is do you think he's
doing this intentionally or is he
oblivious
I mean me and my [ __ ] mind yeah I
think he does because uh intentionally
yeah I think he's a [ __ ] nut job and
uh it's obvious you know or actually you
know what maybe he does it maybe he's
that delusional where he just doesn't
think so I I don't know I'm gonna I
agree it has to be intentional because I
mean the eyeball thing is like
it's way too [ __ ]
obvious right like how could you for not
realize and you're not even the first
person whose eye he [ __ ] up he he
blinded his friend it's the other guys I
thought that yeah
so that's pretty crazy dude I don't know
man
let me pull over so we could dive deeper
into this yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
don't want you to
I was watching her earlier I saw you
guys are dropping those cards the H3
cards oh you like them you want to pack
yeah they're cool yeah awesome I'll put
you in touch with the guy if you want to
make some cards with them he's a good
dude
please yeah Jeff I'll hook you up
hey that's him right now hi Max yep I'm
the guy who made them yeah
oh nice to meet you Max is here yeah
yeah yeah so uh yeah we could we can put
you in touch
yes so yeah I just saw this and I was
like damn I wonder what Jeff thinks if
this is intentional if he's just like so
[ __ ] unbothered by it I don't know it
seems intentional to me
probably unbothered to be honest you
know
I mean it's it's a pretty stupid thing
to do he's either trying to piss me off
or he just doesn't give a [ __ ] you know
which he hasn't given a [ __ ] and that's
what the whole thing pissed me off about
it was you know yeah and he I mean he is
actively though like thinking about you
because it has any told like all the
other Vlog Squad guys not to associate
with you at all
yeah that's true you know I'm sure he's
it's it's crossed his mind but I try not
to think about
what he's up to you know hey Jeff I just
cut all I just cut the double hair a mo
a hawk off what do you think about my
new do
I can't believe you kept it for that
long I know I thought you'd be impressed
by that I had it on for almost like
three [ __ ] weeks dude at least
yeah but this girl killed it I actually
went and followed her on Instagram no
beef no no hairdresser beef she's
awesome yeah she's really cool
it looks great thanks man thank you I
had a fun hair Journey with you it was a
good time
so what can we do in retaliation what
can we do to Jeff to or what can we do
to David like a sculpture that we can
make to piss him off
that's a good question because I'm down
if you I'm down to do something if you
but you know what I mean like what's uh
oh well somebody you heard about
somebody uh spray painted rapist on his
on his um
pizza place oh yeah yeah I saw a
keemstar that had a funny joke there
yeah he came yeah he did good I hate to
say it but yeah
the streets don't forget you know
I just wish you know that that they put
like an eyeball on there or something
you know that'd be nice maybe we just do
an eyeball statue ourselves our own
reclaim the eyeball for ourselves didn't
he throw like a pine cone at his
friend's eye and blind and maybe we get
like a Pinecone eyeball excavator thing
or that you might not want to see that
though too
no I don't mind the excavator that
doesn't bother me so maybe we can have a
ball
what do you think about this uh rumor
has it this is going to be his Halloween
costume next year can you see this
can you see oh my God yeah so this is
out of this is way inappropriate this is
not cool at all
you know he
what you want me to say about it yeah it
[ __ ] pisses me off
um we could go on and on about it you
know I was having a nice day I was out
on a nice ride all right yeah yeah yeah
are you texting and I'm like what the
[ __ ] did he do now you know but I'm
happy you brought it to my attention
because it just goes to prove how
delusional he is you know it's insane
it's insane I mean it was on our subred
with a lot of points by the way Ela just
messaged us she she's donated ten
dollars and said hey Jeff
thank you
Ela just donated ten dollars to me and
said hey Jeff
cool yeah let's think we should yeah go
ahead
well
I mean what what do I want here I want
I would like that statue that'd be nice
for them to send me that statue you know
oh
yeah if you win you could ask for it as
part of the settlement
I can put that in there huh
yeah
um you could for sure and I for an eye
maybe we could make an eye for an eye
thing
yeah maybe we can we should try to
commission the same girl to make some
crazy ass David dobrik style I from an
excavator and a pine cone or some [ __ ]
you think that was her idea the artist
because you can't know David and not
know like
I guess maybe some people do but for an
artist you have to look into somebody's
life and is that like a sick [ __ ]
thing that they would do I heard a
friend she specializes in making eye art
she like only makes eye art yeah which
means David pursued the IR girl
yeah that's which yeah exactly that's
[ __ ] insane
I'm sorry bro I'm sorry I just wanted to
get your thoughts but I got you all
fired up now but let's think of
something I'm furious thank you Ethan
yeah yeah
thank you yeah enjoy the rest of your
day
with this one as uh first time ever Jeff
whittak calls into Frenemies
person only time yeah you know what
exactly let's do that let's wipe the the
Slate clean what a great first call what
a great first call we had from Jeff
first time ever thanks for here we love
you Jeff I think it's the recurring
thing where you guys just called me and
just bring up some stuff that'll piss me
off throughout
yeah
yeah I'll keep it coming man I'll think
of you next time I see I see something I
or excavator related and I'll just get
your thoughts on it all right I
appreciate Ethan you're my eyes and ears
on the street yeah absolutely well look
chill love you guys all right Jeff take
care thanks for calling we love you too
friend of the show great friend of the
show Jeff whittick uh
family for sure always family just make
sure Cody gets the memo on that okay
thank you
[Music]
bye Jeff thanks for calling Jeff
whittick ladies and gentlemen what a guy
sweet man
you didn't deserve it just didn't
deserve what David did to him did he
can you pull up this artist uh I'm just
curious what our other art looks like
like how
yeah it's in the dark maybe not no I'm
not unless and I'm not listen the artist
is great I'm not nothing against the
artist I just want to see yeah how far
uh David went into commissioning her oh
yeah I mean it's all it's all eyes all
the time first of all just to be clear
I'm not I think the artist is great she
didn't do anything wrong she just makes
cool eye [ __ ] that's awesome and it's
actually all pretty pretty cool it's
yeah it's beautiful
yeah
what's your name right and her jewelry
too is really fun that's really cool but
so but like what I was looking for
is that okay so she does make these kind
of sculptures but David got the bloody
eye gouge one
and I don't see a lot of those
he's like I want the most realistic eye
popping out of the head [ __ ] you got
because yeah I don't see much of it the
only other one I see is this one but the
one he had was like bloody right
mm-hmm it was blue and pink but
yeah the red
the pink red it looks like
blood you know what I'm saying there she
is the eye lady well we love her and we
hate David that's the vibe we might be
reaching out soon for a commission yeah
we might be commissioning our own
we want a piece called an eye for an eye
there it is Jeff whittak ladies and
gentlemen
um
uh there is one more thing
that [ __ ] pisses me off you guys
heard that we were trying to get Elon ma
to call into the show
and he big timed Us big time well we
offered him a thousand Yuan which is
like 300 bucks and he told us basically
to go [ __ ] ourselves he said don't waste
my time basically
okay
well dude Perfect's out here
they and they got Elon ma like two days
after our us talking about it definitely
stole the idea from us by the way and
wouldn't be the first time dude perfect
stole an idea for me or or do you think
that
Dude Perfect gave them an offer and
they're like okay they paid us this why
would we do this for a thousand you want
if they got to him first stack might be
right they might have set the bar too
high they I think that's my yeah you
know by the way dude Perfect's been
ripping me off for a while you know that
idea they have to like do trick shots
and [ __ ] yeah I've been doing that since
I was like [ __ ] eight wow what's your
sickest trick shot that you've ever
pulled off dude uh I could flip a red
cup
just flip it yeah flip it up and then it
lands on the bottom
so it like starts upside down and then
you flip it and then it's right side up
you sometimes I can hit that sometimes
like 25 percent
I'm telling you those guys are idea
thieves have [ __ ] piss me off you
ever um you ever in your travels of
trick shotting you ever take like you
know like a 20 ounce bottle of soda and
you take it off the the lid and then you
kind of like pinch it and it like
and it like shoots you ever just like do
that your friend the [ __ ] you talk you
mean when you get the bottle cap and
yeah like yeah kind of like and then you
like do it at your friend's head and
they're like
dude why'd you do that yeah yes I have
Dan sick dude
it is [ __ ] sick it is thank you for
bringing that up
so dude perfect got to yilon and I don't
I don't have Dude Perfect money these
guys are like insanely popular what do
you think they paid him thousand bucks
I'd say 10 grand yeah
I think they gave him equity in in the
in the mega complex I think he owns ten
percent now Zach you're not serious you
think they gave him 10 grand I think
they said [ __ ] it I mean it's an
exclusive
bro there's no shot anyway here's the
video he just made a tick tock for them
it's not even like that big yeah I'm
perfect
uh connector with me uh
to perfect
hair window
s
I love you
that ain't worth 10 grand that ain't
worth 300 I'll be honest that was it
that's it I didn't know what the [ __ ]
he's talking about was that supposed to
be promotional
I love to find out hey hey uh message
him Zach and ask how much did Dude
Perfect they will match it I just sent
you that Discord we're gonna find out I
actually I actually have some
interesting Intel there's a fan or a
viewer of ours that message ilama uh and
started talking to him and for a
thousand dollars he said he would do it
and he speaks Mandarin and everything I
put
I I'll put Zach in contact with him I
think he he can set it up for us I'm not
paying him a thousand bucks
he will do it for a thousand bucks maybe
we can get him down yeah I bet he would
either way no way we're getting down I'm
not his name is as a thousand dollars
for this [ __ ] what do you want how much
to do perfect pay you we will pay it yes
it will match it okay we'll match it
well you're just gonna have to take his
word for it it's gonna be fine I'm just
curious about 40 000 yeah I'd love to
hear him say that you know that's not
true million you on
you're kidding yeah you didn't hear back
you're just yeah never mind dude perfect
so there it is I'm gonna go watch this
again because I I'm trying to understand
what's the objective here
uh Dude Perfect
uh
at the Peter space dude perfect
with me
what is that what
do you say here
right uh
Too Perfect
hair window what the [ __ ] is that share
mon Mundo
Because
by the way
experience he turned the experience into
like 10 syllables it's really
interesting never heard that uh
I love you bro I don't it's what I'm
saying I you know what I mean I don't
know what the [ __ ] they're even trying
to promote
the golly
just him saying dude perfect is enough
you know if he says H3 yeah that's
that's amazing I I don't know that it's
worth
I don't know that it's worth 400 let's
see 400 USD
to Yuan
that's what I I was 3 000 isn't that
what I offered him
um
let me double check all right well let's
see what dude perfect paid I'm dying so
so we the last offer was 2000 Yuan okay
okay
that's three hundred dollars
but what what about Twitter space like
are they doing a Twitter space with them
nobody said they're doing a Twitter
space and then somebody's going to space
it sounded like well the dude perfect
one of the dudes from Dude Perfect went
to space okay they like paid for I think
it was the Bezos like trip or whatever
it's like 300 000 or something yeah
something like that I'm not sure
is that a video on their on yeah I saw
the other day it's pretty cool
nice you didn't do any trick shots while
he was up there though so idiot loser
what the [ __ ] he didn't do trick shots
in space that would have been the best I
just scrubbed through it maybe he did
actually but they probably have to get
the whole thing because I think there's
like eight seats and so if you wanted
the whole thing it'd be like two million
bucks probably uh right yeah there were
other people in there that like weren't
part of the the dude perfect I wouldn't
want to be filmed for a Dude Perfect
movie if I was you know what I mean
I think this might be a this is not
actually a dude perfect because
Moon Dao the thing he said it's like a
cryptocurrency see I was wondering if it
had something to do with crypto because
Dao yeah exactly but the caption it was
all one word so that was throwing me
they even showed the channel dude
perfect but I think you're right why
would Dude Perfect pay
long Mao like it's a scam that's not
something that's acting like is he
promoting a scam I think so because Dude
Perfect is not interested in all this
kind of weird internet subculture wait
somebody says he's Shilling Moon Dao
crypto with dude perfect is Dude Perfect
part of this Moon Dao thing
this is this perfect moon this is so
weird dude they paid him in crypto there
you go
oh dude perfect goes to space with
crypto project Moon Dao okay wait Dude
Perfect did a crypto collab to go to
space god damn it dude these people are
such [ __ ] shells nine million shares
I mean it was one week ago so it's
timely it would make sense that makes
sense but I'm still not sure how this
helps them
I'm still not figuring it out I guess
they should start took a trip here yeah
so what is official Moon though
it's
it's just some crypto the first doubt to
go to space shut the [ __ ] up the
Internet space program
oh this is so slow there's the post is
on there so time to invest so how much
should they pay him I guess they got
that crazy crypto money
this is so dumb I'm actually gonna [ __ ]
and piss it's so dumb
um
it's so dumb like what we did is crypto
Elon mod Dude Perfect in space it's so
[ __ ] dumb it's all meanwhile FTX is
crap is going bankrupt because again the
owners like doing fraud and crypto is
like again basically down to
[ __ ] all and like we're stilling crypto
who the [ __ ] is doing this
small note their posts with Elon uh has
63 retweets and only 108 likes that's
what I'm saying
why would they pay yilon ma his 10
billion
fee well you have your answer they're
paying him in this token
you didn't even get that in on the
ground floor early investment dude like
this who wouldn't want to be here you
want to know how this thing's a scam you
want to know how this thing's a scam go
back to their Twitter profile it's
literally it says we're going to the
Moon literally it's their whole thing is
we're going to the Moon damning people
that's [ __ ] literally dog whistle
scam [ __ ]
we're going to the Moon literally
this thing will be at zero in two months
going to the Moon
crazy why dude perfect working with them
like you guys have enough legit sponsors
it's just like send them to the [ __ ]
space I mean that is I guess
I would play this video but every time I
try and fast forward it Twitter's uh oh
it's got music
yeah I don't just I don't want to go
look he did do a trick shot
okay
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait
it'd be funny if they just had a
horrible crash to Earth that's a hell of
a trick shot so oh you're so good at
trick Trucking why'd you crash on Earth
they should have trick shotted the Pod
into like a giant [ __ ] that's why
they're building the building it's it's
the land like you know that building's
all crazy [ __ ] yeah it's gonna like land
in a funnel and then yes you want to
impress me dude perfect [ __ ] trick
shot yourself into a volcano
yeah I do
then I'll be impressed
until then leave Elon Musk alone he's
mine
[ __ ] up the whole Market
all right let's talk about my my uh car
getting stolen now at long last oh and
then we can do the egg drop which I'm
we're all super excited about
okay how where do I begin with this um
[Music]
sword to talk about
[Music]
um
250
000 to go to space per person yeah how
many seats is in it
looked like eight or something
yeah yes that's a lot of money also it
is expensive and also like you're only
in space I recall for like five minutes
or something like it's really really
yeah it's a quick little
but I guess if you have all the money in
the world it's cool I mean I'd do it if
I'd had a quarter million dollars do you
trust that Bezos is tech there to not
blow up
I mean so far so good right
yeah and also I mean what they're doing
is I mean not to downplay it too much
obviously it is cool but the the quick
up and down trip like that I mean we're
talking about what the Mercury program
was doing in like the early 60s like it
it's I want to say it's easy but like as
far as space stuff goes uh quick low
earth orbit all you need is one loose
tile brother I mean that's true it's
true it's still risky for sure but it's
relatively safe I would say yo by the
way somebody tell yilong ma that
bitcoin's down 75 this year
you doing okay love with the crypto
no comments
nah I mean at this point whatever [ __ ]
it
somebody says well Ethan just say you
liter of your car and move on
that's not what happened that's not what
happened yeah no it's not what happened
how I got where are they downplayed yeah
so um foreign
he's upset guys don't this isn't funny
this isn't funny audience no it's not
actually so what happened was you guys
heard that I had got like the first BMW
electric car I was super excited about I
was gonna get rid of my Tesla electric
car
because well obviously [ __ ] Elon Musk
but even more than that it's just nice
before it was like Tesla's only option
and now there's so much competition
coming out and I was just super excited
to get this BMW SUV to replace the Tesla
we pre-ordered it a year ago
a year ago
custom [ __ ] made
specked out put the deposit and
everything
Lena has been talking to them Lena you
want to tell them what happened BMW this
is your customer support go ahead Lena
yeah I'll try to be as nice as possible
well no I'm not going to be mean but the
customer service was horrible so yeah as
Ethan said you guys have been waiting
like a year now for this custom ordered
BMW and when I called last week to
follow up on it they're like oh we
already gave it away they said the car
arrived and there was someone there at
the dealership that day who wanted it
and they sold it because there was that
one you were kind of on the fence you
wanted to look at other electrics ELO
was freaking out because she's like oh
it's got a bad review and I was like
I'll take it I'll take it I'll take it
you can take my car
yeah so we were just wondering with the
dealership we didn't cancel the order
but we were just curious if we were to
back out what would happen
um and I guess they just went with that
and you know since there was well no
he's like you can't get your deposit
back it was 3 500 yeah yeah and well we
said okay okay cool we just left it open
and then this [ __ ] it wasn't
open we had the reservation we paid for
the [ __ ] thing
and we never canceled it
and I guess he just like refunded us
without saying anything and then just
pawned it off to the next person yeah
that's weird I don't know how he would
go through that without even like
letting us know he refunded and didn't
say anything did you confirm that they
sent the money back Lena I'm waiting for
um your accountant to get back to us so
this is this is a common thing you paid
a deposit right 3 500 bucks we ordered
the specs and everything that's what
I guess to put this nicely waited a year
dude that's what pieces of [ __ ] car
dealers can be yeah it's so [ __ ] up
but BMW like did and this is my first
time going BMW okay I've never had one
of their cars and um this is my first
experience with BMW I gotta say the
Germans have done it at the German right
yeah
okay as a Jewish man I expect better
from the journey okay but here's not
[ __ ] twice this will never happen
again we said here here's the thing
though when you ordered that car you got
it at MSRP you were gonna pay MSRP
there's yeah at least some [ __ ] that
came in that they're like oh we can
charge them an extra for that new car
probably an extra 25. well you know what
pissed me off
they pawned our car you're right do we
pay smrp for that Lena probably because
we just pre-ordered online it's like
they didn't even
and then they go okay but we have one
that's similar right super rare they say
too a [ __ ] liar yeah it's like and
that's what really got me so mad too um
he his response was horrible when I was
telling him what happened and how could
he do that he's like well if the car is
gone you know there's no point in
arguing we have this other car here you
know that your boss might like and I
just I couldn't believe it so so the
other car by the way
similar car up charged like thirty
thousand dollars they probably charge 45
for years then if the one you ordered
was better they're like no no this one's
marked it's a similar car it's just
marked up twenty five thousand dollars
[ __ ] I said hell no bro [ __ ]
that where's the where's the BMW CEO who
can I talk to that's how it is right now
that's [ __ ] but how can you do that I
pre-order what's the point of a
pre-order it doesn't I pre-order the car
I put the money I got this [ __ ] that I
like so what what the process doesn't
work you order more cars then it doesn't
it that's how dealers are they're always
looking to find that quicker higher Buck
BMW yeah shame on you it doesn't matter
we haven't forgotten BMW
we haven't forgotten what you did we'll
never forget
yo never again we said we said never
again is that really BMW everyone during
World War II BMW made
uh
planes for the Nazis and stuff I mean
all German companies did obviously so
there's a bit of Hitler and everyone
never again I swear to God I try to give
you guys a chance and this is my
experience
my own car taken away from me like the
luggage of passengers off trains in
1942.
it's outrageous it's unforgivable never
again
it's a shame I was excited for you guys
to get that car because I personally am
a fan of BMWs I wanted at least the ones
made after 1945. but what kind of
[ __ ] this is like insane like how can
I and good faith go back and get a car
after that because they were like so
rude and mean to Lena too they're like
well it's gone so what do you want to do
I couldn't believe it so I can attest to
this because she was on speakerphone
talking to the dealership and I I she
was outside and I stepped out and was
hearing some of it and I couldn't
believe
how much of a dick the guy was you can
hurt him talking yeah and also Lena was
fired up I've never seen Lena fire yeah
it's a warrior I knew she'd go to bat
for us but yep it was both the sales rep
and the sales manager they teamed up on
you or not not the same time but you
know once the the rep wasn't doing
anything and then I spoke to his manager
and he was even worse they cut her off
mid-sentence and like laughed about it
like why are we still talking about the
car is gone what do you want me to do
for you
amazing like that [ __ ] said that
that's so [ __ ] up dude like okay well
that's never happened to me at other
brands I mean it's just not it's just
not happened it's not happening to me at
Tesla that's for sure I guess I'll be
working with them again BMW [ __ ] you
well Tesla differs and like you you
order a car and it's not really like
they have a deal there's no heckling
right which is cool that's the one
that's actually [ __ ] got right
I love that all right by the way happy a
thank you for the five gifts thank you
thank you
so I don't know man and and you know
I thought it was free speech people are
saying name the dealership no no
no don't do that nice try chat you guys
really wanted me to forget ruin my life
over here
BMW once assured my dad
did not speak English soon assume my dad
did not speak English and suggested he
would be more comfortable out of four
dealers
what
it's pretty [ __ ] up he's like yo
listen
we don't take we don't deal with uh
no
listen you don't speak English I'm gonna
assume you're poor I'm assuming that's
the subtext all right go to Ford
I don't like BMWs personally I gotta say
I [ __ ] hate BMWs you know yeah I mean
it's the dealership obviously yeah not
yeah but it's their cars they're they're
the ones that are letting this happen
well if you run it up the chain like if
you want to go what chain
call corporate BMW corporation on
corporate Lino
no I haven't let's get the [ __ ] I
swear to God oh yeah no they won't they
won't be happy about that I'll go to
Germany right now
you can tell corporate the dealership
I'm not going to say it on stream to 40
000 people
love can I go with you I'd really like
as much as I'd love to because sure it's
not worth it you never know they might
not do anything yeah I didn't think
about pursuing it further you know
because you know no one else has been
able to help yeah you're gonna you're
gonna get a hold of the president you'll
be like look the car's gone what do you
want me to do it says the same thing
saying it in German hold on let me let's
hold on let me let me plug you into the
board of directors listen the car's gone
what do you want us to do lady not 10
people
honestly if you do call them as much as
I'd love to see this they're not gonna
do anything they're gonna think
nothing's wrong Zach is black filled as
[ __ ] because I've been through this this
ring around for [ __ ] years like it's
just [ __ ] well the thing that's
really crazy is that our lease on the
Tesla is up in like a week and we
specifically timed this so that we would
get this car right and return that one
and then they [ __ ] not only did they
sell our car to someone else they didn't
even tell us they didn't say anything
they just returned the money apparently
I haven't even confirmed it to my bank
account without saying a [ __ ] thing
after telling Lena the the the uh
deposit is non-refundable yeah that's
just how they are man and it's
unfortunate it's shitty dude [ __ ] you
and I feel the car market needs to start
turning into more like a Tesla thing
like I think that is a great [ __ ]
idea and how we buy cars but you mean
buying them like literally every other
product that you buy pretty much yeah no
for some reason doing this one [ __ ]
price that's why the carvana thing is so
cool that people are really into it you
literally go to like yeah that's where
CarMax does that too dude they have the
big towers like a gumball machine you
put a coin in wait what yeah what are
you referring to like yeah
and it comes down in the elevator a big
ass [ __ ] Tower with cars in it gotcha
yeah when you pipe when you pay for it
they give you a big ass token yeah now I
agree I I hate that
cars it's just culturally you have to do
this is this the case in other countries
like love when you go have you ever
bought a new car or you know I know you
always drive one thousand dollars I know
I get it but but do you know like in
Sweden is there this whole like dance
like haggling dance that you do when you
go and buy a car or is you just you pay
what they ask for I mean it's fair I
don't know honestly I don't know I don't
buy new cars ever okay maybe somebody in
the chat knows if like in Europe if they
have the same we have dealerships but
not uh I don't think many people buy new
cars here to be honest they're always
old
um
yeah I don't know so I'm kind of [ __ ]
now I don't know what even to do it's
like super pissed off and it's just so
[ __ ] up yeah I don't know if it's a it
seems like a breach of contract
I mean well did you sign a contract with
them
we must assigned something right I don't
know I have to look yeah I said the
money except uh that's the thing too
there was no like cancellation form that
was signed though just the that refund
receipt that they showed me
which also that form wasn't signed
either so yeah of course it was a sign
we didn't even know what happened
stupid bro it's just the common case of
someone they wanted more money at that
time and they weren't willing to wait
and it's shitty it's really shitty
yeah well they [ __ ] me so BMW I'll I
said never forget I give you another
chance and here we are
you know
it's just not right man
it's just not right just line me up in a
in a [ __ ] line and make me dig my own
grave while you're at it
[ __ ]
the car is trash anyways don't worry
it's like
oh my gosh maybe you should get a Volvo
go with a nice Swedish or a pole star
Volvo Swedish yeah yeah
I prefer to drive a volv up yo
[Applause]
sorry sorry
you know what I mean just put just why
don't you sentence me to five years of
hard labor while you're out on three or
four I don't know what it was [ __ ]
bro I swear to God
just when you thought the Nazi party was
over
[Laughter]
we see your last name is is the uh Klein
oh
we said he's fine as a German last name
I might have thrown him off a little bit
maybe that's why they originally were
going to sell it but then they did some
digging wait a minute damn [ __ ] it's
true probably don't mind [ __ ] over
other Germans
[Music]
so oh and about the car crash yeah I
bumped my uh
I bumped my car into a curb but um
it was devastating yeah I know it's a
little scratch on the rim it's fine
though
oh no stolen I mean no I sure that's not
what I meant I meant stolen which means
uh well it was stolen yeah it makes
sense you had a car stolen for me yeah
the BMW [ __ ] dealership stole it sons
of [ __ ] [ __ ]
what can we we should we go up the chain
Lena let's cause let's kick up some dust
dude what rules
what rails maybe maybe you could tweet
it oh
oh [ __ ] sorry you know what that you
know what it's okay because that doesn't
work Marriott still left me on red so in
my situation dude I talked about on the
show and they still were like [ __ ] this
we don't give a [ __ ] they probably
promoted that dude
good job keep the Ruffians out content
Court their ass
God damn yeah so that's it I don't know
I'm never getting a BMW
all right brother I'm calling you out
looks like he shaved his tiny mustache
you [ __ ] me for the last time don't
make me draw a mustache right here yeah
and show your true colors Heil Hitler
kind of like the or Oreo guy
what did Dad just say Ohio Hitler that's
Dan what the [ __ ] that's a sound bite
seriously out of context would you have
Jewish yep sure am I would never
I'm calling you out president of North
America
I demand reparations
you stole my car damn it
don't you know what you've done to my
people
ain't no way I'm going through that
again is this Jewish cowboy yeah we're
getting lost
Jewish stuff and it was such a Shonda
just talk like you were talking okay
where's their headquarters based
what city I'm not asking for their
address it's public information BMW city
they're located in yeah I'm gonna guess
they're in Berlin no no no North America
uh they probably are in the South let's
see so that's what I was doing North
American headquarters BMW is in New
Jersey New Jersey I tell you what my
back in the South I'm coming to know
Josie and I'll be
I'm picking I'll be doing protests never
again
never again we said ugly
I'm getting all my brothers and sisters
we can have a dosey doe out there bro
a dosey doe for freedom
Shalom on the Range
[Laughter]
yeah I'm so pissed bro [ __ ] [ __ ] BMW
I'm never going BMW I'm sorry dude
that's shitty what am I gonna do I have
a week to find a car now go to a [ __ ]
Audi Man Superior car Audi I want an
electric car they have them Audi has a
full electric car e-tron
check it out they're Germans too though
it's true they make the most and highly
engineered car no Audi has a full
electric car yeah the e-tron it's an
it's an SUV it's the same size as these
are you serious yeah it's pretty cool
actually it's a great [ __ ] place SUV
it looks just
like the model y
at least the back does do they have one
on the dealership uh Lena
it's probably going to be another like
year round no those are easier to get
than the Beamers because the Audis have
been out for a minute oh okay well the
thing is we called well he's like yo we
have another one we can sell you so it's
like it's not that [ __ ] rare it's
just it's gonna cost you twenty five
thousand dollars more and on principle
I'm not doing it yeah yeah [ __ ] them
yeah that's [ __ ] you know [ __ ] them
this is fully electric
yeah the e-tron
e-tron e-tron electric SUV
is Golden Gloves to Tesla's MMA what the
[ __ ] does that mean it's a weird analogy
it's a real SUV
I'm sorry Dave yes sir I'm afraid I
can't do that should we call them Lena
should we see if anyone has one of these
in town yeah we could and we can just
say tell BMW to suck a fat donut between
the two the BMW does look nicer yeah
I was pretty excited about it I'll just
be real
all right it's preference
he's a beamer hater
I just feel so burned you know
I thought you don't like Beamers I do
like Beamers but Audi's a superior car
okay we could just go through a
different dealer and then that way
you'll get your BMW
right
yeah just don't reward them but I just
want yeah okay thank you we'll figure it
out but that's that is the click bait
got you guys [ __ ] got ya Ethan's car
was stolen that was a good one that was
av's idea so round of applause to a B
for that one thank you thank you I'm
learning yeah it was a good one really
good one
Mr Beast past PewDiePie and sub count
apparently
that's pretty incredible that was fast
you know he didn't pass though
my boy's a T-Series let's go tell me
serious [ __ ] rules dude wait how many
Subs are they at I don't know
they might not Tori who says Kia
ev6 what Kia has a fully electric car
too
T-Series is 229 million it's not even
[ __ ] close bro they're dude they
literally did a lap around PewDiePie
yeah they laughed at this
dude t-shirt is goated dude that's
insane
yeah I mean they post like 100 times a
day
the views they get are nuts
and it's not fair India has more people
more bigger pool to draw from although
PewDiePie's International okay let's
move on let's move on so it's Mr Beast
okay I'm super excited now we're moving
on to the main segment it's gonna be so
much fun you guys are going to want to
watch this it's the egg drop competition
we have five teams of two here's how the
game works first of all what are the
teams it's I know it's me and Dan yes
and then uh ab and Lena yeah Ian and Sam
yeah Zach and Cam and then Olivia and
love which that's gonna be interesting
love you're just gonna have to be
yelling at Olivia uh what you want her
to do that is interesting I trust Olivia
those shoes yeah okay
so the rules are this we're going to
draw a number out of a hat
one through five
one goes first five goes last you can
pick three
items from the table
only three not including tape
to make the most cushioned egg drop uh
pod you can
when the team is done
we are going to the top of that what 15
foot uh how many of how tall we got
there
and we're gonna drop it
and see does that egg survive and maybe
we can even have a tournament where the
winners go on to a round two
I'm wondering though because when
William does it he drops it off like a
two-story building I'm wondering if
that's not high enough if they'll like
all not break but we'll see
I don't know if it will maybe we need to
throw it up in the air at this
throw it up yeah that'd be good
although the dropping can be messy you
drop it and then you can control where
the impact is that's the whole point of
that
let's take that element away all right
oh so it's a 360. it has to be a 360.
all right so let's pull let's pull uh
the first contestants there
from the hats damn I'm gonna well I have
numbers in here so it's gonna go by so
me me and Dan will go first
come on Dan Dan is drawing give me that
number one
okay I like to I like to
um
two me and Dan are number two loving
that I'm gonna draw for Ian and I
the sooner you go you're at a huge
Advantage for rest in peace
because as the items get picked they'll
be less great items there I'm gonna go
for me and cam
Cameron and Zach are choosing I believe
in you Zack get us number one five five
ouch brutal
looks like Sam's or it looks like Zach's
gonna be using the maxi pads all right
that was my
my focus
number three so I think that leaves
that's just one number right so there
you go all right so a b and lean are
stepping up as our first contestants
let's get up to the
activities table here so you guys have
three minutes or was it yes or no how
long two minutes two minutes and three
items so hold on
hold on turn around don't look at the
items no strategizing ahead of time we
come on we gotta get right so
um
Dan how you doing back there you're
getting the camera ready okay
how are you guys feeling you're feeling
confident oh yeah very I mean the first
place is a coveted spot you guys are in
really good shape there yeah yeah
oh I can't look okay we can't look yeah
we're feeling good confident you guys
talk about this beforehand no you just
asked me right now do you know what
we're doing and I said yes yeah all
right so we are waiting for Dan to um
prep the camera there
Dan is prepping the camera how you guys
doing any weird uh Shenanigans at your
apartment recently I know we had a
squatter next door which was weird
because usually our Apartments haven't
had any problems like that that was
interesting
um besides that nothing really how'd you
know there was a squatter there I heard
like some thumping next door and I have
never seen a neighbor in my apartment
like ever like any neighbors ever it's
kind of weird I went outside and there's
like three cops uh with one of the
neighbor ladies who said she heard the
shower turn on
and somehow alerted how do you get the
cops out for that that seems kind of oh
where we where we live I mean I don't
know they don't cops don't mess around
there really yeah I've
I haven't seen one homeless person there
I've heard that the cops I don't know if
it's true but I heard that cops pick up
the homeless by where we live and drop
them off downtown yes oh yeah Dan agrees
really yes but it was that's great again
in Olivia yeah yeah yeah okay so
okay guys so did you have a timer back
there uh Ian or I can do it on my phone
all right let me get my timer open so
um as I start the the timer guys you
have two minutes you will begin your
selection
and uh
building okay you have two minutes are
you guys ready yeah okay okay and go
all right Lena and a b
oh the catcher glove you only get three
items
and the tape the tape does not count
okay
here we go
yes
but do they have to build it in two
minutes too
you guys have to build it in two minutes
in theory the bra one one minute 30 left
okay well we have to build it next time
too
okay three minutes to build it
[Music]
okay okay good good okay I got it all
right you guys
and we'll wrap it with this if we get
unlimited tape so we get one more
no we got three items okay what do we
got what did you think
you guys
oh we don't have eggs wait pause the
timers I said bring the eggs out yeah
the eggs the eggs are meant to be here
well hold on you gotta put we gotta
pause the time so eggs
the egg drop
not an airdrop
foreign
so I think you guys had done like 40
seconds is that right or a minute
you can just leave the eggs on the table
there
yeah
okay great all right so uh go ahead
start the clock in thank you Sam here we
go uh uh uh Ian you've got the clock
cracking my balls man best show on best
show on the internet folks
okay all right I'm gonna start on mine
you have two minutes okay go go all
right we have two minutes so what do we
got we got the cloth what is that
there's a where's that diaper a diaper
a styrofoam foam cup and a bag of cotton
balls
okay do you need to rip pieces for you
yep
[Music]
EAB is furiously shoving those cotton
balls in good form good teamwork Lena is
preparing so the egg is inside the
styrofoam is that what's going on
okay so they have an egg but I'm not
that big Jesus okay hold on yeah you
don't need your teeth time you have um
hold on you have a minute 20. you guys
are looking pretty good on time
now the Styrofoam cup is wrapped in a
diaper okay
no big big big big big okay
okay and you understand the words are
coming out of my mouth
[Music]
this is just a diaper now they're
wrapped let's just wrap up it's okay we
have unlimited tape you have one minute
left you have one minute left
so they're just going hardcore on the
tape here guys what else could you
do I mean that's it we could use this
whole bag yeah yep that whole bag is
yours put it put it one big one one big
one you have 45 seconds
my God you guys maybe unlimited tape was
a mistake we're gonna have any tape left
after this
this is a whole [ __ ] thing that egg
is not broken y'all we got time to
to chill man we're good you want to call
it it's you yeah call it we don't need
it let me cut them off how much time do
we have 20 seconds yeah while we can and
again this is the advantage of the uh
number one I knew someone was going to
grab those cotton balls oh my God the
tape when the tape is stuck
but I think the challenge really begins
on the next round
maybe you guys use a whole roll of tape
huh
wait do we have anywhere to open it okay
that's it that's it that's it all right
all
right
good teamwork there by ABM Lena
hold that up for for everybody so we
have a styrofoam cup
with the egg in it surrounded by a
cotton balls
and a diaper taped up in a diaper in a
cotton ball bag taped up
but let me get a hold of that how much
are we weighing here
oh yeah you're gonna have to open that
later this thing is light boy this thing
there's this is not breaking I was
wondering if somebody else not on the
team should be the one to uh should I
just I want to like throw this at the
wall
uh Ela just asked me Teddy asking what
are you doing
cute teddy we're doing an egg drop
it's a game where we have to protect the
egg as much as possible and then throw
it at the wall or drop it really high
and see if it doesn't break and so
that's the game hi teddy I love you how
are you hi teddy I miss you yeah
say hi all right let's step into here
and we'll see what's the best way to to
challenge this so let's go
all right
Okay so
we have this ladder set up but you know
I feel like most of these are gonna
survive that so one thing I can do is
maybe toss it all the way up to the roof
from the from the ladder though
what was the difference if I throw it up
here I guess same thing this is the less
risk of death
all right ready so I'm gonna throw it up
at the roof here we go
oh
I don't think that there's no shot that
bro
can we now do we check it out yeah check
it out let's get some scissors and yeah
it's very delicate there's no way that
bro
feeling confident yep I'm hope so hope
my baby's okay
okay he's talking to me where's the
scissor oh lean I think the scissors are
on the table
we're always prepared here at the nature
podcast
I'll be I'll get it started
I didn't hear a crack I didn't hear
anything
I think you're gonna survive yeah that's
survives I appreciate the confidence
guys you had a whole bag of cotton balls
be more pressed if it broke
okay here we go you want to do it no go
for it
my shakiest hands I might crack it going
in
okay here we go oh my God
drum roll here we go
okay here we go
okay here we go and here we go all right
let's check back in with them
okay
here we go
all the way down oh I'm seeing diaper
seeing diaper
there oh yeah
to the diaper we need to wrap the
quartering up in one of these you know
what I'm saying
maybe we've grabbed too much tape
or something
be gentle I am I am I'm always gentle
men
shaky and gender he goes oh I did almost
pierce the egg with the scissors oh wait
did you break it he almost said almost
there's a big hole in the Styrofoam cup
be careful I don't care if hey he's
getting into it now
talk to me baby talk to me
she did it yeah there it is intact
it's a little baby well done guys
okay AB hold on to that egg because
we're gonna need that in round two
that's your egg
all right Dan me and you are next
I have a great idea Dan I think you're
gonna love it
is there any tape left or did they use
all of it there there is two okay good
maybe maybe less tape though for future
contestants but I appreciate what you
guys did you guys played within the
rules okay Dan you ready let's do this
okay so um Ian whenever you're ready
[Music]
just put it in the local breath
okay like how good is that yeah
[Music]
it's since we have to secure it yeah
should we wrap it
in math or like a bra I like the backing
pad wrap okay
pork and beans is pretty fire if that's
gonna hit it let's go yeah jello
all you could do is put it in them oh
that's good that's good put it in the
jello in the bread okay that's good
that's funny okay it's been 30 seconds
all right let's
okay good
job let's all right okay
so let's here let me I'm Gonna Keep the
plastic so let me open this okay
delicately and then here hand me the egg
please don't we want to do the job yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay
I'll start getting some tape oh man cut
them off
you used a lot of this yeah just shove
it in there one minute and then oh my
God
is that okay yeah get in and then close
it wait we only have one minute what are
you talking about hurry up good one
minute where's the [ __ ] tape where's
the ridge oh Jesus where's the ridge
here it is here it is all right so let's
Tape close the jello all right it looks
pretty good actually okay
here let's just we don't need a lot of
tape is that good jello
foreign
that problem that happens a lot dude
this thing ain't breaking in that jello
that's already good enough bro yeah you
can throw this off the [ __ ] building
and it won't break all right so now
we're going into the bread
now should I carve out the bread or just
shove it in there I think just get it
between there like a like a stacked ass
sandwich yeah okay here it is so we're
gonna put that there right there yep
okay get that thank you thank you thank
you red boy get that bread boy
all right so so oh [ __ ] I gotta I think
I gotta let the air out yeah like that
okay good so just yeah wrap that wrap
that up and we're going to want to get
it the long way so it stays nice and
tight I don't think we need more than
that do it really tight around the the
long way there good good good
the tape drops okay I'm gonna go grab
the tape when this is done we have still
about 30 seconds so we've got time we
got time
not just on the back red
but that's complete the look at that
dude
we're good
hell [ __ ] not all right 20 seconds we
got it
[Music]
oh yeah oh yeah it's done dude
it's done call the contest now
look at that 10 seconds
baby nice
all right all right let's do this yeah
thank you thank you all right that's a
genius egg right there wow all right so
who wants to slam this thing
no you're operating the camera
[Music]
all right we good we're hearing this all
right so just hit it on the roof and
then it'll come down and we'll call it a
day all right here we go
perfect oh that felt hard
oh okay this one's actually a lot less
confident though I where's the scissors
okay to be fair you threw that part but
I think the problem is is it has a lot
of weight
that's true but that thought sounded bad
but I think it's gonna be fine all right
here's the jello okay look at this [ __ ]
Amy
yeah I think I think we're gonna be okay
I don't want to break it on on the
extraction process
Howie Mendel scary oh [ __ ] I think it's
broke no
okay hold on hold on broken careful
extraction no don't lose this hold on
I can't [ __ ] believe it the Fortress
of the Fortress
it's like surgery
open the wound oh [ __ ] oh God my friend
Neil dump it dump you can put in here
take it out huh
yeah it's cracked bro it's [ __ ]
cracked
oh
no
why is this happening to me
wow huge fail all right well we're
eliminated that's it
dude no
[ __ ]
what soul is happening
foreign
[Music]
oh my God I'm so [ __ ] pissed
I can't believe it
why do bad things always happen to good
people are you crazy are you out of your
mind I think the biggest Factor there
was the wave
you want to keep it alive
the tip I don't want helping you guys so
what happened you swapped out for love
since you're here physically I just have
arm arms yeah arms is good that might be
helpful So Max and Olivia are the new
team here
I love obviously let us know your
thoughts yeah
okay that's cheating no I'm just kidding
love you can help
but let's be real
perfect
all right no I'm kidding love you love
you you're with them you're you're with
them he can be your avatar thank you Max
families come in all different shapes
and sizes they say families too we got
these guys
when the clock is ready and let me know
people are saying who is Max Max is the
uh Trading Card guy yeah
if they missed my life if they missed
the beginning yeah yeah are you ready
Ian all right guys go okay
all right
[Music]
they got a big bra
[Music]
maybe show the table more what's going
on on the table
yeah
so we got the bra
we got what is what's in that bag there
baby socks okay that that could be
useful
I don't know I feel like shaving cream
can you stand on the other side maybe
stand on the other side of the table so
you can see the stuff on the table
yeah
show the table
so we got a bra we got marshmallows and
maxi pads okay interesting combo
so wait can they have unlimited maxi
pads that seems fine right yeah yeah
okay so we've got marshmallows a giant
bra and maxi pads I don't know guys you
have two minutes go and an egg yeah yeah
and the Egg of course so I'm gonna wrap
the egg in a few pads first okay that's
good and those are Max flow or light
flow these are Max flow okay good
that'll be helpful heavy dude that'll be
helpful for sure yeah yeah well the egg
has heavy flows the egg has a heavy flow
and and then you guys are have down to
about one and a half minutes I don't
want to talk about it it'll get rapping
should we do another yes one more love
you have any thoughts on their approach
here
um no so perfect that actually looks
solid that looks solid and then it feels
light too yeah
we have marshmallows now what size cup
is that bra I would hit it with probably
a d oh that's so that's a that's a
that's a big bro and it's a push-up too
which means it's extra good now why do
you need a push-up of your size d I'll
give for the lift I guess yeah the lifts
also you know the sleigh of it all okay
okay that looks very good very promised
hold on have we tried the marshmallows
one minute one minute love is asked a
question what's up have we tried taste
tested the marshmallows no but I'll I
got it all right good
can I have one
those are good
that's 40 seconds
again I can't believe I broke that's
just [ __ ] bro
I think Dan's got to throw them all from
now on
with the same velocity cut them off
20 seconds
foreign
there it is
so ultimately we have
an egg wrapped in maxi pads in
marshmallows and marshmallows in a size
deep broth with duct tape with duct tape
yeah
all right to give that to Dan he's gonna
be the master Slammer today
competition is fierce here ladies and
gentlemen
um
[Music]
people want me to use the ladder I have
a feeling I'm gonna die I'm using a
ladder yeah you are but it hits the
um
he's right he's right he's right I'm
pissed ours broke spike it dead are you
ready yeah don't what the [ __ ] here we
go
so Dan threw it at the ground not as
hard as he could but
I think it's I don't think it's broke
there wasn't a big impact there yeah
it's so soft I think we're good actually
we should just
uh-oh uh comment says you push up bras
have great padding so that was a good
choice there
I think you guys are gonna be in great
shape this game is gonna really heat up
in the next round when all the good
ingredients are gone
foreign
you guys have the scissor right Olivia
yes so the next round is going to be
really interesting because I'm looking
at some of these ingredients
and there's a way to make it work but
they're not gonna be easy
so Dan tell me about how hard did you
throw it
well I felt like because I was up high
you know I already had the added
velocity provided by uh being at the top
of the ladder
so I think that's better than throwing
it at the roof I I felt the floor shake
from over here from the impact I mean it
felt the floor shake I mean I felt you
know some impact of it
it seemed like people are saying audio
everyone's saying audio Echo
[Music]
it's picking up on the thing over there
so who are you talking to who's me yeah
what did I do I'm sitting right here
oh oh they're put Mike's picking me up
yes okay
okay
I'll just not talk
okay let me attack that good job guys
hold on to that egg
you're gonna need that in the next round
which I am not in
because Dan had to slam ours on the roof
you told me to
all right who is number four number four
up next oh it's Ian okay
um you know I thought me and Dan coming
together on the same table would bring
us together but it turns out he was
Sabbath he was willing to sabotage even
himself to get back at me
Sam and Ian
stepping up
competition is fierce we have two
competitors moving forward
Sam and Ian how are you guys feeling
today we're not allowed to look over
here yet no but you yeah but you guys
set it up yeah you bought everything you
know it's there but okay all right
whenever you guys are ready Dan you got
the timer there do you want me to do it
three guys okay guys
one two three get after it go
okay it's egg it's egg drop time I
I I like
the cooked ham
what about let's see the cups are gone
cupcakes
what about the beans we put it in the
middle of the beans
so wait we want to lock in the sponges
so okay okay I don't can you hear them
well I don't know all right so we got
sponges
we got ramen soup interesting cup of
noodles and uh cooked ham okay wow now
this is really interesting popping this
open right okay you got yeah two minutes
left now
fish
not that bad it can't be that bad
now these rough sponges are soft sponges
what's the texture they're pretty soft
okay okay okay so okay okay so damaging
this in there
interesting so Sam got rid of the ramen
the new oh my goodness that is just a
whole brick of ham right there dude
they're putting the ham in the cup of
noodles we want to just Nest that's a
cup of ham right there boy
put it in okay the egg is going in
between the careful
now they're gently putting the ham and
the egg into the cup my hands are
shaking
it's a it's a high tense moment Ian you
know
okay so that so you guys shoved that
full of ham but pack it tight pack it
tight like ham chew oh they take a bite
to keep the energy up
how's that taste Ian I'm in here it's
good you have one minute left guys you
better hustle okay
all right all right yeah you guys are
running out of time oh my God we're
needing napkins 50 seconds no
um oh this is getting hectic
here you're trying uh 40 seconds this is
getting hectic I can't get it
cut them off your fan is struggling
because of the ham juice okay she used
her teeth she got it undone Sam is using
the ham juice to lubricate the tape okay
this the sponge just two sponges on the
top
we're wrapping it 15 seconds oh my God
you guys
ten nine eight seven six seven keep
going five more swatches more three two
doctor doctor
all right all right we gotta cut we
gotta cut the tape here do we have a
I appreciate that Dan you gotta see you
gotta laid a lot
okay all right let's take a look at this
thing this is an interesting one
again as we go deeper in the game
the CH it gets more challenging now can
I take a look at this this is very
interesting you guys made so we have an
empty cup of noodles
stuffed
what about it it's not Korean at all
okay
yeah so um
stuffed with canned ham yes and covered
in sponges this one is got a lot of
weight to it so I'm wondering it's a
little grenade I'm wondering how it's
gonna go but Dan it's your job now too
okay okay yeah oh God no no no those are
harder than me dance the egg Destroyer
we are so done
oh [ __ ] oh my God this is like pretty
steep bro
don't fall thanks man
[Music]
you went all the way up
yep oh [ __ ] this is gonna be the real
life
my ass already looked like Humpty Dumpty
are The Kingsmen here or what
come on this is scary I don't like
matters it smells it does all right you
guys ready
all right so like Dan like a medium
throw
uh medium heavy oh okay
yeah
okay which is super impressive very
delicate
[Applause]
it's so difficult to remove all of our
good tape work here
[Music]
I mean that was a good throw you know
there's a good impact there it smells
like it stinks dude I'm gonna be so
excited for you guys but that's not
broken
what
are you okay
guys all right
I can't believe
that Dan are the only idiots
who got out
next okay so that was four now we're
moving on the five great job Sam and Ian
true competitors in every sense of the
word
and I threw that boy I'll tell you what
man I just showed no mercy on that ham
bomb
all right so up next is Zach and cam is
that right that's all right that's right
so our final team here and then we're
gonna go off to the next round we'll
re-pick numbers
because the order is going to really
come into Factor there and
um hopefully we'll be naming an egg
Champion here a uh Cam and Zach how are
you guys feeling your last so obviously
at a disadvantage last of the best my
friend yeah we're creative we can get
this we can make this one two creative
Geniuses here dude it's like SpongeBob
and Patrick
so we know which one Zach is
um
timers right do that again Kim that's
how Tom Kenny does it he goes oh really
yeah
oh [ __ ]
all right you got the you got the Glock
ready uh Ian
foreign
guys on your Set Go
three minutes on the clock
are those Takis those are takis or
Pringles
you know I tried Takis for the first
time last week I did not like them
didn't care for the Takis the flavor was
insane this is controversial you like
hot Cheetos I love Hot Cheetos and you
did not like Takis yeah because the talk
is too sour it's like too much lemon you
can catch heat in the comments for this
lime is so important I know people love
sugar is also really bad on Takis what
is this slander Hot Cheetos I love it
have you ever had the fries yeah the
Flaming Hot Cheetos they're good I'm not
a big fan they're okay yeah they're okay
okay wow these guys selected faster we
got Hanukkah wrapping
um a pack of takis and then what a
Donuts you guys got tape too I'm
assuming put the egg in there Fuego
yeah put it in there so you're using the
Takis that are in there yes okay
interesting and takis are pretty hard
aren't they oh
yeah
all right all right come on just use a
different egg it's fine that's really
funny though oh my God our Takis hard oh
we're gonna find we're gonna find out
okay so you're patting the fall with the
donuts and we're gonna use the power of
the Jew you know interesting
I'm not feeling great about it but you
know
put it in there man not too hard Zach
dude if you broke it again Zach I can't
did you break it no we're good okay good
well you have a minute 30.
you guys are gonna win the whole
tournament watch yeah shove that those
uh Hanukkah we don't have the Joker
brain for this
all right so we're all packed up [ __ ]
up man you know what you never know this
could work out for you guys I'm gonna
hold it down I'm gonna hold it down and
just tape the [ __ ] out of it
I feel like this could it really depends
how it hits the MacGyver [ __ ] right here
my guy
yeah all right there it is you guys have
one minute we need more tape more Donuts
there's some extra padding oh
interesting not a bad idea yeah should
we go vertical or horizontal
how many donuts are in there you could
you could place them around
strategically yeah they're
I don't think strategy is out the window
here today folks
come on we got this baby
oh okay I like that no you can't do that
you gotta you gotta cut it off
tape is tape it's not an impact object
all right all right I think we're done
wow that ended 30 seconds early look at
that now this is this is interesting
like a gravity bong now it's got a
little weight to it I like that the
donut impact thing there on the side
yeah you better hope it lands on that so
we have talkies which are pretty hard
yeah we don't have much to work with
what do you use yeah rubber duck instead
rubber ducky I don't know yeah yeah I
mean obviously yeah the options are
limited you got the egg
and then the Hanukkah uh
part of the Jew my friend so people are
saying it's crazy enough to work I think
it's so
[ __ ] so here it is should I do it then
or you want to do it uh I can go back to
doing it yeah okay you should still come
over here though for the sake of audio
though okay so look at that doubling
effect and is going up and he's gonna
slam this [ __ ] into the Earth at
medium to hard strength
sure
come on
okay here we go slam that I put a little
a little English on this one a little
spin we'll spinsky you could have got
more impact than that
arcade okay
I'm just saying everyone's been through
the ringer here you guys don't get a
free pass yeah
[Applause]
all right okay okay yeah I you know what
I think there's a good chance you guys
are gonna survive this
here I'll do it on the dude on the tour
okay here we go here cut this yeah yeah
time to fly Dan said
and certainly it was that
um
okay we're ripping open the the duct
tape here the truth lies in the talking
of my friends
come on power the queue baby here we go
come on baby didn't break
I feel like oh that shit's that shit's
cracked as [ __ ] oh no it's crap
okay can we get a shot in there yeah no
no just dump it no and I wanted to eat
those yeah dump it out
oh God that thing is devastated [ __ ]
dude yeah nice try
and hold on let's do it before we go
back here fist bump first get that out
of the way thank you um come over here
follow me real quick
there's been an incident
you dropped the egg
[Music]
pigs that's my baby oh bro dude I come
in here you let me in here I ruined your
game I ruined the show
s up
all right pack it up
dude killing a baby is a huge party kill
this audio
cam got a freebie so you guys should get
one too I guess
look at this Milk Dud it's the smallest
milk that I've ever seen
it's so little it doesn't even look like
you're holding anything
okay so we have left
nice try yeah the cam and Zach you guys
were working good effort at a handicap
there being the last contestant but love
you Cam
the excitement is really going to turn
up here
in our second realm
we have left lean NAB
olivience and Max by the grace of God
wait no there aren't they out
I said they should get a freebie of
camera okay
you know
Sam and Ian is that it
yeah uh yeah there's three teams
you and I got eliminated and Zach and
cam got eliminated so there's three
teams still in this
so we need to randomly select the order
again okay here I'll set that up
where
anyone here from Arizona
you got the paper in there yeah okay so
we're gonna select the order here
and this could but I'm sorry the
smacking sorry guys I took the worst
[ __ ] candy you could do milk thuds
are we using what remaining items are on
the table yes okay
yes
okay go ahead
okay
and I got five [ __ ] my life you're going
last you ain't first you're last
okay
that is the good one yes
[Music]
all right Olivia and Max please step up
the championship Realm
sorry about the Milk Duds guys I
literally I'm like Mr Ed with peanut
butter about here
I don't know what the [ __ ] I chose Milk
Duds of all goddamn things to eat honest
during a live show
it's like [ __ ]
it's
oh come on
how are you gonna milk an oak ruining
all right guys
this is the championship round I have a
feeling
it's gonna turn up you can only choose
from the remaining ingredients there
three minutes
you guys ready
I have a question go ahead we picked
balloons is it one balloon or is it you
got the whole pack the whole pack
interesting I think that we can do
something with that you guys ready do
you think so yeah of course you guys
right guys go ahead start
so are we blowing up all right Olivia
and Max and love
oh thank you Ethan
Olivia has
gone straight for the balloon
she's already blowing them and she's
trusted Max
looked at the coffee filters
cut them off you guys have one more item
to pick there
well our baby just died we're still
dealing with that babe it's a baby sauce
so go ahead sit Max
okay I like baby socks I would like to
put our egg in the in the baby
so you guys got balloons coffee filters
and baby socks yeah yeah yeah and what
if we like maybe we want just need
something like this that's what I'm
that's what I'm loving and then and then
balloons like around one minute down
so so we're inside the baby sock with
the egg we're starting there can I do
the other baby socks too is it all yeah
[Music]
thank you we got a whole collection of
baby socks ladies and gentlemen how much
time they got I don't see the clock on
the screen they are there you go 1 30.
so the baby sock is going in the coffee
holder that looks interesting
that looks interesting
okay so the egg is in the coffee filters
okay well you guys have a minute 20 now
it sounds like this is getting pretty
complicated but we're complex people
okay well you have a minute there'll be
a cop as complex as you want beings
okay coffee filters are being
taste up
one minute left one minute guys rattle
your Dags
do like oh we need more tape what's the
plan with the balloons there
feeling like maybe like one here are we
out of two
don't think too much about it just tape
them into it so so you guys have about
40 seconds left and we are just going
what is what is this up y'all gonna try
to try to float away with this yeah
[Applause]
I feel that those balloons are not gonna
do anything because on impact they're
just gonna get pushed aside but I could
be wrong I like the Ingenuity certainly
that's true that's true yes
listen I'm a huge William Osmond fan oh
[ __ ] 50 seconds 15 it's a terrible day
10 seconds
nine eight seven six five you've covered
the timer four three so you cover the
timer two
stop
this is what I was looking for all right
hand me that let me take a look this is
actually this kind of looks exactly what
we intended okay that's perfect then so
we have here oh it's very light so
that's making me feel good for you guys
thank you baby socks egg wrapped in baby
socks inside the coffee filters with a
couple balloons and then the deflated
balloon on the bottom it's like the
rudder yeah it's gonna help with the
direction during the drop I think all
right let's Dan do your thing it's a
Hidden Mickey or you want me to do it
I'll do it yeah
it's a beautiful combination of us both
here we go
the real egg drop at the end said my fat
ass cling into this thing
with sandals on and [ __ ]
all right all right
here we go
so I'm feeling damn just at the ground
right yeah sure okay here we go guys
I think
did it I think so yeah
I think the balloons actually slowed it
down
oh that lens flare wow
oh this is very cinematic with what's
happening right now
easy easy
here we go
it's so bad
oh I feel a little wet on this oh no
there's moisture detected in the middle
which is obviously not a good sign but
let's see
the baby sock where'd the moisture come
from I don't know maybe oh the ham Maybe
inside the baby shop what do we have
all right now where are you good how are
you guys
I feel a lot better that's the second
egg you guys broke you're out and [ __ ]
yeah I think that's
you know what we did a beautiful thing
today yeah
I like the Box yeah no it's cute it is
cute yeah she likes it though yeah she's
with her brother yeah yeah she's with
her brother
[Music]
Olivia
they won the realm
and dropped the egg
the second egg they've dropped by the
way oh you're Frozen Ethan one second
they can hear me though no sanctity for
life on that team
absolutely numb
they Murder My Children
I know love ma'am
yeah I'm good
my goodness
how are you feeling Olivia
[Music]
devastated yeah you were so close to me
I feel like we just met our eggs and
they're already gone that's exactly how
I feel
it feels just like that yeah yeah it
feels just like literally mean when it
feels like that all right well
unfortunate accident uh
aside you guys are out that means
there's only two competitors left CEO
Partners
um I believe up next is Ian and Sam is
that right
all right Ian it's Sam come have a seat
hmm
one of two teams remaining yes the
inventory there is getting very low
I know I'm trying not to look over there
and so
um this time to get really creative
we're still here
I can't believe that didn't break dude
it was beautifully snug and right at
home in that ham you've got to hold the
egg though my hands all dropped it all
right okay are we ready
all right guys and build
Slim Pickens over there
go they got beans for sure
Ian is wondering if they should go for
the Ziploc bags
wow okay that was a quick decision so
they picked Ziploc bags
a can of
of baked beans are those genuine English
beans or fake ones no uh no no no
[ __ ] and do you think the
bullshippings are better at impact okay
we should put and shaving cream
put the cream well here maybe we'll put
one of these eggs
okay now watch the uh I can't at this
stage of the game I can't forgive
accidents guys now load it up okay so
Sam is squirting oh no oh no okay Sam is
squirting the shaving cream into the bag
interesting
uh you have one you have two minutes
left two minutes left milk
so here here let me put some in this bag
why so little
trust the process
trust the process Sam says in response
to my inquiry
so we're getting some bag and foam
section here
yeah Sam is just okay nope
I should trust Sam she is our prop
Master she knows what she's doing oh
wait do you think is that good I think
that's good okay they have three bags
full of foam
and at the heart of it an egg
okay what's happening now interesting
I'm gonna do it one more time yeah
holding a bag then are we gonna put you
guys have one minute twenty one minute
20.
Sam is doing one more thing I thought it
was gonna work
it's too slippery I was attempting to
insulate it okay okay now oh wow wait
that coffee pot's not yours brother so
I'm just putting it down okay okay okay
good good that's fine so with they have
put it in the bean bag
trust me oh I can't put it in there that
is a tiny can of half a can of beef
Ian is trying to shove it in a canopy
there's no way
look out okay so he's pouring
corn beans and shaving cream in a bag
okay and then that one goes don't let
some of the air out we're running low on
40 seconds guys we're good this is
definitely our most interesting round
yet I mean this is good stuff all right
we're down to our 30 seconds here Ian's
got
Ian's got shedding foam but he got the
tape open it doesn't does duct tape
stick to uh shaving foam we'll find out
today put it in this bag wow
that's good no this is good 15 seconds
it's in there 15 seconds
uh ten nine eight seven six five four
three two one stop stop
stop stop
okay okay guys
um this is I would say
the most interesting shell we've had yet
all right so wow this is just
you know this could this could work I'm
gonna be real with you guys there's a
lot of
of padding in here so you have
the egg in the middle of several bags
full of shaving cream
and then the final bag stuffed with
uh beans beans and shaving cream yes
wrapped in duct tape yes
I think this is gonna work you guys
you want me to I'll do this yeah
all right
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
that smells
all right I'm approaching with my hands
covered in shaving cream
here we go
Humpty Dumpty
climbing up this fish I gotta take off
my sandals next time because yeah they
get more and more sketchy
all right you guys here we go
this could be for the dub you guys
here it comes
fly
oh it hit the hand
thank you
it Slams on your hands
yo wait it exploded though Chestnut
Checkers my friend
okay
there's the beans
but all right here we go it smells kind
of good over here yeah the shaving cream
is very aromatic
I think you guys are gonna be fine
this is the best unboxing we don't feel
like it hit the ground super hard
let's go to open these there's lots of
layers to this one here my hands are
here I can't do it don't throw the bag
down careful
yeah Ian's stepping it it's a
battlefield in here it's dangerous
[Music]
it's not so easy maybe the scissors
oh do I see yellow I thought I saw
yellow
wait careful maybe let's run it under
the water and see
I think it's I think it's okay let's see
okay we're gonna run it under the water
[Music]
what do we see
that egg is good let's go
yep that's a whole egg
damn that was impressive y'all
that ham saved you though
nah
go ahead
that was the ham of God right there
reached out
we're all good you could click we're all
in line to wash our hands
the shaving cream wow
wow
wow
okay baby
I hope you're plotting a b you're
thinking of the Moon
I'm so hungry yeah
I'd even aim for the ham for sure come
on back
you know leaving the debris on the
battlefield Maybe
[Music]
look how much shit's on there now
well it's only fair for you guys
so Ian and Sam survived
with beans and shaving cream
incredible our Sam's just cleaning up
the desk real fast for you guys
common salmon Ian dub right there dude
that could have been the dub yeah for
sure
Lena Abe how are you guys feeling
confident still that was really
impressive of them but I feel like we
could do it
I'm a little worried I think team
smelly's Gonna Take It
well Leo let's take a look at what's
left on the table
it's not much
foreign
don't forget about the um
sardines
oh the Ethan knows from the penguin
costume excellent
that's disturbing
straws
those brownies could be in clutch
all right guys how's the clock we
looking good
all right Lena and a b
get building
I'm ready
all right
Lena and AV Fierce competitors
and wrapping an egg
okay AB is
taking the lead here Lino's gonna be
wrapping an egg in Band-Aids or with the
not with the box they've selected the
toilet paper rolls
and the brownies oh [ __ ] we don't got
good tape this is good uh it's not as
strong all right that's good tape that's
fine that's fine
here but you need the tape first okay
here we go they're quick to the table
it's not it's not confident and fast
true competitors
okay he's wrapping wow the Band-Aids not
even out of the keep them in the package
you know
okay okay
so more Band-Aids this is what the bear
feels like I'll get the paper
what's that Ian have you watched the
show The Bear the bear no yeah it's like
a cooking show it's just like oh really
yeah sounds good
hey can you throw me one of those
brownies are you gonna need them all
I may need them
all right so what if we execute this
it's just Band-Aids and brownies at this
point right
that's all we've got really is Band-Aids
and Brownies so we need
wow it's a triage out here man these
guys are working with purpose
um stick with the tape time one and a
half minutes remaining a b is now
putting it in the brownie box [ __ ] it
he's saying we'll use it all like I
didn't know about this
Elena is just stacking the tape like a
true
Lieutenant cut them off like a true
General Brigadier General hold on hold
on they haven't even used the
the rolls yet
just going hard on the tape are you guys
going to use the rolls there the empty
toilet paper rolls yeah we'll get to it
we'll get to it okay so now he's all
right he's adding the Bus 50 seconds
guys okay that's plenty of time this is
an Abomination but I'm liking it I'm
gonna get the broccoli yeah I'll start
wrapping wow Ian or a B is really going
for it here
wow you can you can really feel the
passion
and these competitors
you guys have 30 seconds come down
you guys got four 20 seconds left
a b the human tape machine
whoa whoa okay yeah that's fine that's
fine
how much [ __ ] tape this guy is did he
stick to one roll how many roll he is
seven six five thank you four three two
one okay
stop we got it dude that looks good
bring it over here let me see
to be honest I don't think this one's
gonna make it my concern is that it's
heavy my concern is that the egg is not
cushioned enough my concern is you're
not gonna hit the meat
when you throw it
that's true that makes a big difference
so
we have an egg wrapped in Band-Aids
wrapped in
brownies brownies boxes and then wrapped
in uh toilet paper rolls somehow but
it's all wrapped up and it looks like a
Christmas present so let's go slam it
there we go
[Music]
wow it's serious
jacket off
why'd you take the jacket off and the
socks off it's gonna be a completely
different person
I was afraid of dying that's why
fear of death
all right guys
you like no I should aim for
away from the ham I think you should aim
for like yeah
all right guys here it is
for the championship
lean in a b
for salmonium
what the
no [ __ ] I think it's fine
that was the dentist drop I think
I think it's gonna be fine
there's a lot to cut through
the tension is mounting oh it stinks two
compete what stinks in there I mean
that's
okay
slow down you don't want to cut your
finger off or break the egg
okay came and get to it how you guys
feeling you think that exits what's your
thing I'm not feeling confident about
this no yeah I I think you guys are
going to be fine I'm hopeful so hopeful
they're correct you can tell
wow we got we got ham on the ground
that means of course
here announce it back at the table
and that means of course
that we have a champion egg drop
Champion 2022 it's Mr verified back at
it again and his lovely partner Sam
Sam creative director prop Master they
sure know what they're doing back there
you guys have taken the dub Against All
Odds that shaving cream and bean was a
master class and egg dropping how are
you guys feeling right now so like is
the hand the hands up for of her crabs
right yeah you can eat that now okay no
one throw that away uh Sam's Sam's the
prop she's the prop Queen you know
quick thinker
when I saw that that canned ham at the
Dollar Tree it was like the dollar
Gambit in my head
wait was that a dollar the canned ham
everything here smells like a sense
store you can get a can of ham for a
dollar yeah boy
is their lives worth more than that
that's like a huge can I meet yeah I
mean it's like cat food quality but but
yeah still a pig lived for that yeah I
agree it's sad America baby after I got
that canned ham my Tick Tock algorithm
showed me like 20 recipes with that
canned ham oh
um it wasn't it wasn't that bad that
eating like stinky meat I'm in my zone
man that's my element yeah I mean
compared to fika that's got to be a you
know like pumpkin pie yeah well this was
such a fun time and I'm just so proud of
you guys so once again Sam and Ian say
hello say Thank you Mr and Mrs Egg Drop
2022. wow and a gracious thank you to
the competitors it was some juice
real juice real juice real juicy thank
you true stuff there it is
congratulations thank you everybody for
joining us egg drop 2022
you guys will be getting the grand prize
as a gift card to Sharky's yeah
three dollars so you can each get a
salmon burrito
the weirdest of all burritos you still
excited about that yeah Ian thoughts we
literally were at Sharky's what was that
like four days ago I've been hitting up
Sharky's recently really you guys are
back on the Sharky streams good it's
good it hits our yo can I recommend
something to you Ian yeah they have this
Mexican pizza it's so [ __ ] good like
it's just it's ridiculous it doesn't
make sense I can't believe you got back
on the Sharky screen you haven't even
told us this yeah this is a big
Development I've been embarrassed when
I'm back on
awareness wait keep going what is it try
the Mexican pizza it's like the super
thin it's like a chick barbecue chicken
pizza super thin bread and it's like
amazing wait has no business being that
good
let me pull up a picture so everyone
knows what to get for dinner okay
yes Sharkies for those of you that are
not familiar is a uh
fast food Mexican place fast food how
dare you say that that's fast food this
is not fast food notoriously mediocre
also look at this
would say that I think it's I think it's
okay it's not fast food it's it's food
it's definitely it's like brisk food
it's like a brisk walk it's not it's
like higher quality than McDonald's it's
like real food yeah yeah
I mean yeah I suppose so
in its own way Dan's not giving me that
I think it's I think it's still kind of
fashionable but try this if you if
you're feeling adventurous it's really
good it's all good oh my God
let me see more pictures from different
angles you've talked so much [ __ ] on
turkeys
it's so good it's so good
God I would eat this every night look at
that
and the crust is like crispy boy I would
eat the [ __ ] out of that
sure would well that was fun
here is the End by the way uh trying to
break the egg
[Applause]
that's my uh
boots my a boot
a dude haunt me for years
okay so how long we've been going
there's a few we've been going for three
hours so let's wrap up but I want to
save some of these stories for uh so
what's what's our schedule for the week
Wednesday is Howie yeah Thursday is uh
leftovers as usual and then Friday is
Bradley Martin
oh
um
yeah sorry
um
so I was confirming with uh Bradley's
people this morning to make sure
everything was kosher and he uh he can't
do Friday anymore oh ow Friday is not
Bradley Martin what time are you gonna
sell me a BMW what do we do about it
what's up Bradley how did that not get
reported to me it it happened oh it's
breaking news you better reschedule him
yeah well uh he's available well we can
talk
we'll talk about it okay so Howie on
Wednesday he is Leftovers on Thursday
and Friday will be H3 podcast after dark
original
that's right actually but Howie is gonna
be
wait did you say oh
Howie is going to be so fun I'm so
excited we have surprises for him we
have a whole show planned out for him
wow yeah it's going to be great and he's
a good guy we're besties we can talk
about anything I'm gonna show him my
rash my upper diagnosed with friends
absolutely
but um I want you guys to I have this
one somebody in the chat said Bradley
can't make it because he just picked up
a new uh electric uh BMW that he needs
to break in a little bit I bet very
funny kjm
real quick I just wanted to say the um
the H3 packs that we had in stock are
sold out
thank you everyone thank you thank you
man thank you everything on the site is
a pre-order it will ship either January
or February of next year peace and love
peace and love peace and love peace
well thank you everyone
um trading just trading without the just
just trade without the vowels right no
value
yeah Trading
yeah so I see some people in shot being
confused there's still more you can
still buy them it's just gonna be come
later in the year he had a certain
amount in stock that were like ready to
go those have no now sold out so now if
you order it will be a pre-order for the
second wave of them that's coming yes
thank you Don yep yeah and there are no
limited Supply on those correct there is
no limited yeah that one they will not
sell out it is a pre-order until
December 3rd uh at 11 59 Eastern
Standard Time
wow yeah it's a great gift it really is
such a fun excited
um
so that is that um
I wanted you guys to save the chemical
peel one I saw this [ __ ] blew my mind
that's perfect after dark content yes I
would love gila's take on that right
right I do too
um and then the the creepy guy I want to
do that one too
and uh I guess maybe the the police
chase if we have time lots of good stuff
left though and guys thanks for watching
uh one fantastic episode BMW if you're
watching [ __ ] you bro never again that's
what they said and yet I trusted you
you know what why don't you just take
the gold teeth out of my mouth
Pawn them off you [ __ ]
people in the chat were saying uh the
pin link wasn't working anymore I'm
assuming because that was the link to
the uh yep I'm I'm updating it right now
okay and I just pinned a new link to the
pre-order page and I will link it in the
description of the episode too so
oh yeah so I forgot to say there'll be a
new see you next Tuesday tomorrow for
members thank you man how many uh how
many audios are gonna have three going
for three oh got him step it up yeah
it's gonna sound like a
audio
um
actually if you guys have suggestions
for see you next Tuesday do we have a
chat room and Discord for suggestions
for uh what do you mean suggestions I
wanted to set up a chat room and Discord
for questions and oh
um q a stuff well they're there is a
room actually uh with a lot of that in
it we could talk about it well I want to
tell them where to go submit it from
everywhere in my room so oh and Love's
room we have these uh suggestion uh
channels where people post stuff but if
you want it specifically for see you
next Tuesday because it's kind of its
own Vibe
um we could consolidate these
I'll just make the room so I can tell
them where to go yeah we'll just have a
room open in the Discord Okay cool so if
you guys have any questions for me q a
life advice
whatever people want me to talk more
about mitzvahs
that's true I didn't make it through all
630 or whatever yeah you can keep going
um
leave those for me and I'll I'm gonna
record it I guess tonight
and uh yeah so that'll be up for members
thank you to our members I love you all
does make it all possible here on the
podcast you make stability
here for us and uh you'll mean
everything so thank you guys
and we'll be back on
Wednesday
for members I will see you next Tuesday
and uh that's that congratulations once
again to Sammy and Ian
and let me just go Um
one last because I'm seeing uh I think
we have a lot of new members recently
because of all the gifted Subs so if you
don't if you're a member and you don't
know how to get in the Discord
basically you in Discord you link your
YouTube account that you're a member on
to your Discord account so you go into
the settings and you go into the
connections Tab and link your YouTube
account once you've done that
you will automatically see a button to
join the server I have an update you got
an update our click bait was successful
my dad messaged me did your car really
get stolen or just click bait didn't get
that far oh we got them
anyone else get anything from their
parents uh my dad has reached out to me
a few times in the past when we had some
real juicy click bait um apparently he
does not give a [ __ ] about your car
getting stolen though because he did not
send yeah this one okay well maybe he's
just your mom what'd you say was Ethan's
car really stolen oh we got two awesome
that's really good two parents reaching
out that's that's a strong click bait
game right there but yeah my mom texted
me my grandma got in an accident nothing
about the show though no I'm kidding I
was like bro you really gonna kill the
mood like that [ __ ] buzz kill dude
holy [ __ ] illegal gas I was like are we
good I'm so sorry
Jesus man that's what I do baby
what if your grandma really gets in a
car accident now she has dementia Shane
driving nowhere maybe that's deposited I
saw my maternal grandmother sitting by
the bank of a swimming pool let it run
down which was also a river
her genital region was exposed dimly it
had the appearance of a thick mat of
hair
she was stroking herself absent-mindedly
she walked over to me with a handful of
pubic hair compacted into something
resembling a large artist's paintbrush
she pushed this at my face
I raised my arm several times to deflect
her hand
finally unwilling to hurt her or
interfere with her any further I let her
have her way
she stroked my face with the brush
gently and said like a child
yeah yeah that's so hard at the end I
could listen to that whole thing bro we
got to get a longer version although the
next part of that uh has um copyrighted
music over it
Careless Whisper over it at least where
I pulled that from wait no yeah
not in the original but the clip where I
found that well let's buy the audiobook
oh that's funny as [ __ ] I bought it I
bought it we have it yeah that whole
thing's out okay I wanted real I just I
gotta wait till the moments right and
listen to the whole [ __ ] Careless
Whisper maybe when Howie's here just
play that in there the guests just are
so flabbergasted by that
they go what is that I go oh uh great
thinker of our time Jordan Peterson Dr
Jordan Peterson the national anthem up
the H3 podcast
Twitter's a [ __ ]
oh one time he was right
guys see you tomorrow for members see
you on Wednesday for
everybody
love y'all
be good
see you next time this is Ethan
say bye bye
[Music]